[Music]
[Music]
hello
i'm just listening to music right now
it's actually kind of lit
[Music]
yo yo yo yo yo
[Music]
how we doing today
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
hey hold on because this is kind of loud
[Music]
hello everybody
okay there we go now i can hear myself
hello good morning
good afternoon good evening wherever
you're from
welcome
how are we doing today how we doing
today
hi joseph rocket cat tristan
haglund
your man's big will
gabriel ace george hello
i'm good
how are you guys
newly subbed welcome man good to have
you thank you so much
i don't want spoilers
uh i wouldn't watch then
it's pretty obvious i would say right
uh why can't i
do anything there we go
is it worth it i have no idea i've never
played the game before
i have no clue
we're gonna do this
there we go that'll be better
i have no i have no idea if the game's
worth it i have no clue i've never
played it we're gonna play it for the
first time today
music's really good off the rip not
gonna lie
i'll turn that up a little bit actually
now i can't hear it at all of course
we'll do that
are you excited of course i'm very
excited
yeah it's a new game that just came out
recently everyone i not everybody but
i've been hearing a lot about uh
[Music]
i've been hearing a lot about it and how
it's like souls games like elden ring
you know what i'm saying
it's a souls-like game
i have not seen any gameplay of it at
all i've just heard people talking about
it that's all could you stream your lore
discussions earlier sometimes i can't
i just kind of stream whenever i can man
[Music]
are you open to sponsorships or brand
deals
yeah
uh you can talk to my management about
that
no i've never played blasphemous that's
another one i've been kind of looking at
too
but
i think we're good i think this is all
right
can do that
no motion blur no v-sync boom
okay
souls like bloodborne feeling but sekiro
feeling too
okay
seven to nine hours to beat
okay
we'll see i'm just gonna get it going
dude let's go i'm ready
i wanna see what this is all about
hermes fortress
the land of alchemy
okay
the people of hermes were protected by
this mythical mystical art and the
kingdom became the most powerful nations
on the continent
that's cool
seven hour stream we'll see how long we
want to play this for today we might
just
we might
beat the game or we might play half of
it and half of it the other half
tomorrow who knows
we'll see how it goes
yeah i haven't seen any uh
any gameplay i've just only heard that
the game is like
dark souls elden rings stuff like that
like bloodborne sakiro so i thought i'd
give it a try
seems like there's a lot of hype behind
it so let's let's go
in the beginning people thought it was
just another infectious disease
it wasn't until the livestock began
began dying and those who had been
infected began shrieking out in pain and
they realized a deadly plague had
befallen them
the various kingdoms tried to fend off
the sickness and ghastly creatures but
their efforts were futile and despair
engulfed the entire continent
hermes kingdom founded atop a colossal
tree where we heard that from quickly
rose to power due to their use of a
miraculous
alchemical science which was able to
blah blah blah as the plague ravaged the
lands they relied on this alchemy to
light the blessed flame
but where there is light there will
always be a shadow
ooh okay
basic controls
move
press l to sprint
look around interact in the pause button
frames
frames
okay we good now
okay frame rate off the off the rib not
so good
okay what is this hello
administrative order due to the recent
epidemic outbreak hermes kingdom is
declaring a state of emergency all
citizens must abide by the following
orders all citizens are forbidden from
going out essential supplies must be
distributed by the knights
any sightings of plague-like symptoms or
must be immediately reported to the
knights to deal with any corpses unclean
objects must be handed over to the
relevant personnel
uh effective immediately all right so
like bad shit's going on that's pretty
much what we're learning here right
all the commands search for corpses okay
they're kind of telling me already what
to do and i don't like that
saber attack
b to dodge enemy attacks
they deal damage to the enemy and leave
wounds on them wounds are temporary and
will heal after a short period oh they
can heal
okay
if no more damage is afflicted inflicted
when the enemy's health and wounds are
both zero they will become dazed
approach today's enemy with an rb to
execute them all right just let me
figure that out
okay
okay
clean
interesting
frame rate not the best any percent
blind speed run no i'm just going to
play the game
i'm just going to play the game dog
pretty cool atmosphere so far
definite bloodborney vibes
i'm having some frame rate problems
honestly
[Music]
is that an execution animation
i don't know
not very cool
hello
deflect
oh we have deflect
really
yeah they took the frame weight frame
rate from bloodborne
30 fps uh just for the enemy deflect
okay
i like deflecting
what do you got what do you got
what do you got
oh okay
i'm bad at deflecting
so far
it kind of just looks like i'm sweeping
okay this is a bad time for this
up on the d-pad for a potion got it
okay
dude that animation is just like
yeah maybe i have to turn v6 on but that
animation of healing is just like
bloodborne where you like get something
in your hand and you crush it it's kind
of interesting
okay options
i've always had v-sync off in like every
game i've ever played
but
maybe that'll help here
because it's kind of
ooh now it doesn't look as good
okay what is this
paper on the ground great name for that
a deadly science
silence hangs over the streets and the
city's completely sealed off there's no
food or water
no food to be found nor any water well
that means everybody's dead
everybody is screwed
um
i already know how to lock on idiot
locking on is just like souls games
that's fine
i don't really like the like finishing
animation it's not very satisfying
i'm gonna have
excuse me i'm gonna have to get used to
the deflection
oh hello who are you
oh
you are the devourer
wield your claws fair apart
claw attack rt to perform a claw attack
deals a lot of damage
to enemy wounds and prevents them from
healing
okay
ow
that hurt
okay
okay
obtaining a plague weapon
each enemy there's a lot of [ __ ] to read
here a unique play weapon corvus can
reeve
can reeve this for his own use hold rt
to fully charge corpses claw and release
a reeve plague weapon so it's like an
ultimate okay
dude the frame rate is really bad i'm
just saying
bad is this like an indie game i mean
it's not a triple a game that's for sure
the day's animations are cool later and
on bosses okay
okay okay
you just started playing this game and
ong bol has posted a video on the final
boss wow good for that guy maybe you
should go watch him instead of me
your forehead
i like the atmosphere though
oh where did you come from
nice
yeah the animations on the like normal
people
are kind of
definitely not like sakiro that's for
sure let me heal
i have zero out of three heals now
that's probably not good it's over here
dead people
oh cast reeved plague weapon
well let me wait on that
beacon
resting at a beacon there we go all
right i kind of get how that works
it's just like a bonfire it's just like
a side of grace
level up unlock a talent plague weapon
potions oh that's cool i like that
yep touch grace
it's a shame it's only on next-gen i
feel like it could be on on old jhin
[Music]
here's their weaknesses
uh when a green light appears before an
enemy attack they will perform a
critical attack and cannot be deflected
instead corvus must move out of range or
used a feathered attack use lt to throw
a feather and interrupt an enemy attack
before the enemy's critical attack hits
corpus
okay
of course regenerated thrown feathers
over time
uh stop him repealing for a while okay
okay okay
so we have undeflectable
attacks
this guy looks sick
this guy looks awesome
owie
oh nice
okay so if i get hit i can't deflect
that makes sense
i don't know your move set yet dawg
there we go
oh
okay let me heal
a little far away there dog a little far
away
did he just deflect me oh okay
ow
charge
nice
this is cool
okay
okay
this is nice i like that the regular
enemies i'm kind of on but you know like
that that's cool i like that a lot
very nice
hello
[Music]
like that felt good to just play as okay
how did this all begin
they said
that an
accident occurred on the day of the
king's birthday previously the plague
was only spreading outside the kingdom
but after the outbreak all have gone mad
oh yeah i keep forgetting the cast
okay next enemy i see i'm just gonna use
it just to learn what it is
i can only use it once it says oh
someone got messed up here bro
i'm gonna go down here or is this where
i already was
i just realized i can run okay casting
okay
okay
i don't know your moves
okay nice mercury counter there my guy
i'm almost dead excellent
nice
okay where were those earlier man
very cool
very very cool
i like it
it's just getting blurry and clear
i don't know i haven't noticed that yet
i need to remember i can run
excellent can't go anywhere over there
uh looks like you can't jump
it's fine
what's going on up here oh god
i'm going back to the bonfire
or what was it called again
i wanna i wanna make sure i'm not saying
like bonfire and runes and sites of
grace or whatever
i know how this works i'm going back
we'll do better next
it was uh
lanterns right beacon speaking speaking
who's this
look at this cutie
okay
yeah i think we're good
it says i'm locked out of upgrading so
that's pretty cringe
looks like these guys are still dead
so they didn't reload when i rested
it's fine with me i suppose
let's check out this it looks like a
boss
hello
hello
okay let's see
whoa
all right who's that
are these the knights that we read about
okay
[Music]
artorias
i died
um
oh my holy
okay
i died so quick
wow
okay
the death animation's really cool
oh you were supposed to die
[Music]
got it
that was really cool
you're finally awake i was worried about
you eyes me
you were badly hurt luckily you made it
back in time
do you remember what you did
you need the right formula
formula to use hermes armor answer
it appears that the injury caused you to
lose your memory so perhaps would be
helpful to start with a description of
what you still remember
come back when you've got your memories
in order until then you can walk around
might help jog your memory
bet bet
[Music]
all right what's this
lot of reading huh the families of the
nightly order petitioned the king to
stop sending knights to battle outside
the kingdom's borders the former
chairman of the institute of the alchemy
of studies emerald has officially
appointed someone to take her position
emerald said that uh she wanted someone
with even greater abilities than herself
to lead the alchemical i can't say that
name
that word research in hermes the
twilight circus hailing from the sea of
trees was once against invited to
perform in a royal court as expected
ringmaster
or odor's
new performance was received with great
acclaim from all who had attended
neat
i like it in here
this is cozy
and cute what else do you want
are you ready to recall
oh okay so that's how i leave i assume
what's going on out here
map menu can recall his memories by
revisiting locations in the quest map
more memories and locations are unlocked
when corvo starts to remember
lit
[Music]
oh so this is how i like go back there
interesting or maybe that's a new area
i'm not sure what the area was called
yeah that's that kid's journal
philosopher's hill is a real family
sanctuary every fall
father would take us here he says that
on the hill he is not king but merely a
father and a friend there is no need for
formalities here he would say after the
outbreak domestic matters became
pressing and our visits to the place
grew less and less that's sad
what are your thoughts on the no no
voice acting i don't mind it personally
um obviously i would prefer it
especially if the voice acting is really
good you know i think it only helps the
game but
um
it's not like if you can't have it like
you can't afford it for your game or
whatever it might be then it's totally
fine to me i think
you guys just get to hear more of my
beautiful voice and my dyslexia coming
out when i can't read
and my little tiny lisp
that maybe you haven't noticed until now
what brings me the greatest joys coming
to philosophers hill with the children
every year watching them run about
playing together
never fails to help me forget the
turmoil in the kingdom recently some
strange sickness has plagued the planet
the lands beyond our borders
i must make sure our kingdom is prepared
neat
it must be the king's journal
[Music]
this is cool
okay
yeah i keep forgetting to run i'm just
like looking around you know what i'm
saying
ooh green
i can't go out there what is this
ancient words by the gate
it is the ex
exploration of former kings
he who examines himself shall never be
lost
write that down chat
write that down
okay we might need to know that later
i want to go up these stairs but i can't
i can't even walk over here
i don't like invisible walls man don't
tell me where i can and can't go
but you know what that's fine all right
kid where are we going
uh sure
okay so i can either use the map or this
kid
got it we're going to the sea of trees
in the early days of the plague the
nobles banish all criminals the poor and
the sickly to a lower level of the
kingdom known as the sea of trees the
upper rings of society leaving living
above the slum
care nothing of their lives they refer
to them as the hopeless
letting them succumb to sickness in all
manner of ghastly creatures
well now i feel bad for them
that kind of sucks
high fiction welcome
how's the game is it as clunky as they
say
um it doesn't feel clunky yet but then
again i have just started
you know what i'm saying
all right sea of trees
i'm definitely having some frame rate
issues
but
it kind of goes away
use memory shards
uh oh i might have to move chat because
the memory shards are in the top right
corner
vitality increases health plague
increases claw damage and maximum energy
strength increases like my attacks
that makes sense let me let me move chat
really quick
i think it turns off the sound for you
[Music]
let me just move it down
that should be fine right there
just so i'm not blocking anything turn
on amd fidelity fidelity
like this
i have a really good graphics card so
i'm just keeping everything on ultra
okay
seems better thank you
it's a ball sack
a lot of ball sacks hello
what are you doing
these are the guys i just fought
ah
hey sometimes it's actually really hard
to know when they're gonna attack you i
gotta learn their attacks
that would helped that would help there
okay the claw is really powerful
this guy's so slow dude
i'm bad
come on
okay i'm trying to deflect too much i
think
this place is gross bro
disgusting
tattered twilight circus recruitment ad
circus is following openings no
restrictions or qualifications all
able-bodied applicants welcome order 20
street vendor 10.
five males five females all required to
undergo a physical examination
performing clinical dues attempt
outstanding compensation chat there's a
job opening if you need it just so you
know what are you doing sir
was he eating somebody
cool yeah i don't know if it's parry
framing or
i think it's just timing
so far
from what i
have been feeling but i could be wrong
oh a ladder
cool
it's basically blighttown that's the
vibe i'm getting here
uh-oh
i'm gonna use the claw on you
cool cool cool cool cool
hmm
claw
or that's when i i can't block them
that's right
that's when i should have used it right
there
the lock-on turns off when i don't want
it to
it could be my own fault
ow
pain
law
okay that is really cool i like it
feel tighter than insakiro's but it's
one of the strongest tools to master
okay
i'm sure it is like i just haven't
gotten the uh timing of certain enemies
down yet
sure it it feels clean whenever i do it
correctly and it feels like my own fault
when i don't you know what i'm saying
like i just hit it too early or too late
twilight circus poster we have returned
a brand new program made just for you
the audience which features acts such as
big clown beat-a-rama dagger's fatal
fatal roll call and the highly
anticipated grand illusionist orders
mysterious finale every saturday and
sunday just on the brink of dusk
you know for a place that like nobody
seems to care about them
at least they have a circus
that's pretty neat oh
okay that didn't feel right but here we
are
hello
ballsack
[Music]
oh so much reading
the exiled who created a settlement that
surrounds the sacred trees these
towering deities protect us from the
monsters in the plague the prophets say
that even just carrying the broken twig
of the sacred tree can drive off
the pestilence
okay
yeah it's a lot of reading i ain't gonna
cap
i don't mind the reading but it is a lot
of reading
so far
okay
shortcut
that i unlock
isn't this where i spawned
[Music]
let me level up i didn't even do that
circus is bad
well we don't know that yet usually
circuses are cool
right okay level up what should i level
what's do you got does anybody know
anything about like what the proper
leveling should be
you have to commit to parrying a lot
more than insecure you can't just spam
it okay
that's good to know thank you
yeah it's interesting so far what's your
opinion on it i don't think i've played
it enough to have an opinion that's it
too much info dumping that's kind of the
vibe i'm getting so far as they're kind
of just shoving
information in my face where i think
they could have just let me figure it
out you know what i mean
i always appreciate that
i guess it doesn't matter like this
isn't a build
i feel like my health is kind of low
let's do this
that seems fine
it's pretty straightforward okay yeah
that's what that's what the vibe i'm
getting for sure
thank you
more hp okay
good good good
are there like ways for me to upgrade my
health potions like get more of them and
have them do more
sir is there sneaky sneaks can i sneaky
backstab
nope
ah my
my balls lick my balls
i don't like where i am right now hold
on
cool
the music kicked in this is good
i tried to deflect an undeflectible hit
i am an idiot
all right that's a bit laggy that's okay
and i'm going into the walls here there
it is
there's the timing we want right there
boys that felt good
let's go this way
you collect potions shards okay thank
you
you scared me
oh hello
calm down lady
honestly i'm just spamming
okay some characters get animations some
don't
consider your claw as another primary
weapon yeah i probably should because i
it feels like i get that back really
easily yeah
bang
it's like when it's in the green here
i feel like when i get them down to like
the green part of their health bar i
should just use the claw
that's the vibe i'm getting right now
no
dodging feels really good did you see
that animation right there where i
weaved in between them
that was cool
owie that hurt
okay i can kind of hold it down and kind
of lock on to the body
that's cool
how we
the walls getting a little bit in the
way there
i'm noticing in this area so far
uh another recruitment ad okay i'm not
gonna read everything
uh memories i don't i'm not sure what
that is that like more
poppy boys uh oh get me out of there
okay
am i supposed to get infected in here
is there another way
claw not your charge claw like just
spamming the
the claw button
they're poppable boys okay cool thank
you
let me go
that's a death skull i i that seems bad
that seems bad what does this say no
restriction to qualifications all
able-bodied okay we already spread that
oh i gotta kill the thingy
oh
we'll go away as soon as i hit it
because this is scary
use claw to clear distances okay
oh i have way more than i thought
okay that was a little confusing the
claw didn't do anything to it
boys remember to break barrels i should
have already been doing that
i should know these things
okay the game plays like near perfect
blend of secure and bloodborne since it
encourages high super high aggression
kinda i don't think i've played enough
to really know that yet
[Music]
okay another recruitment ad yo what up
bro
now that kick hurts bro
i like
these animations
very cool
very satisfying it feels good
except for those those don't feel like
anything
is it co-op i don't think so no
i've been scammed
okay oh my god that is
sad
calm down lady
calm down
okay
fill
your roll
my guy
okay i feel like i need to heal once
okay
[Music]
i'm scared just honestly just because of
the animation let me do this
can i reach that far
no no
shot it was close
let me move
too far away
there we go
there we go
good stuff
what's over here i feel like there's
something here
a ladder okay
exploring feeling good about myself
uh-oh
okay i didn't know how much there was
village elders manuscript i told them i
didn't know what's in the buckets but
they just kept asking even requesting to
speak with villagers who have worked in
the tent my nephew actually worked in
the tent and he said that the buckets
were filled with oddly shaped small
creatures but the circus folk are one of
us the tree bless so how could it
possibly reveal their secret
i mean isn't deflection parrying or is
there a parry button
when did it release like a couple days
ago i think
i was in los angeles all week so i
didn't have like i couldn't play the
game when it initially released that's
why i'm playing it now
oh you can throw your feathers okay i
thought that was just for like
non-deflectable stuff
that's good to know thank you
yeah very recently came out
okay this seems bad yay
uh my character just randomly dove into
the thing
okay how do i um
oh i want to use these
use
okay wouldn't let me go to the right to
use them all just saying
and then there's no animation for it
oh i can unlock a talent
perform fast saber attacks up to a three
hit combo
while in the air use rb to perform a
fast downward slash that looks kind of
cool
uh i have two of these
approach a dazed enemy and execute them
i want that
wait wait oh there's way more of these
oh my wow
this is a very intricate uh like talent
tree this is cool
okay
uh deflect
use the dagger to fend off enemies basic
attacks which okay i already know how to
do that so i'm using these to unlock
them these are things i already have
got it
got it okay
perform saber attacks up to a five hit
combo
i think i want that like actually okay
deflect when successfully effective
attack the enemy counter attack gauge is
reduced
uh reduces 60 of damage
against basic attacks but cannot defend
against critical attacks
okay dodge koz can perform a second
dodge
risk dodge twice and the second dodge is
longer i want that one
and it looks like i can reset these
talents as well
okay
that is really cool
i like that
we're gonna do actually
i'm gonna increase my min by uh health
up to five
yeah you can always unlearn them so it's
not like uh i don't have to fully
go at it i don't have to fully invest in
it i kind of like that
step and jump from the dodge tree is way
better than trying to feather perry
i have more it said i only have two
oh
wait why do i have three now what
where did i get more from oh from
leveling okay that makes sense
okay
that makes sense
cool
uh when successfully deflecting your
block some enemy
some energy will be restored i think
that's going to be important
god's towards an enemy right before the
critical attack hits to jump and
interrupt it
is this the step and jump you're talking
about
yeah i'm gonna get this it's horsing me
right before a critical attack that
seems way better than the feathers
way better than the feathers
you can't harry anymore no that's what
this one says
i'm confused
i feel like claw
oh my god this is a lot guys
holy [ __ ]
um gain a second slot for plague weapons
okay
when taking damage there's a thirty
percent chance to reduce incoming damage
by ten percent
after taking damage a small amount of
enemy energy will be restored slightly
increases the item drop rate i'm getting
that one that's always so important to
have
i'm playing this on steam so it's not
ps5 exclusive now
hello ah
that scared me
okay
we are learning the attacks
yeah i bet you're tired
i tried to dodge into him
what what
hammer
okay
oh i did it way too late boys way too
late
gonna heal
um
hmm
no i tried to i don't understand the
thing
the skill i unlocked
okay i'm just gonna use the feathers
[ __ ] it
maybe i can't do it against this guy
okay i didn't think that was even an
attack bro i ain't gonna cap
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
put it simply
i died
man oh i was so close
i don't know why i did rt
i should have done that way earlier we
are kind of right here though hi metal
when are you getting to 100k you're
saying that like that's up to me my
friend it's not
okay we got this we got this we got this
i need to deflect more as well i didn't
deflect at all
you like that
nice
you like that
wrong button
bad
what was that
messed up
my thing didn't do anything
okay this game's lit dude
okay
this game's lit man
wow
that was really cool
cool cool cool cool
that was that was clean hi maddie how
are
you yeah i totally forgot there's so
many things that i just forget to use in
this
deflecting
does a lot of white damage and opens
them up for claw attack to clear the
green yeah that's kind of what i'm
getting you kind of wear them down and
then use claw to get rid of the green
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah just get 100k dude
yeah we'll just get 100k right guys
we'll just do that
this is cool though i like this game
that was nice now what do i do
hmm do i have any poppy boys
got any rooney boys
uh can we use to upgrade
potions at the binker okay that's cool
love that for me
let's do that
i won't cap you're kind of good thank
you thank you
uh general long lasting
upgrade potion
let's do a mount of potions
to level two
okay
this is nice
plague weapon
what is this
hammer
i like the hammer
cool
what game is this read the title read
the title read the title everyone tell
them to read the title read the title
read the title i'm gonna up my strength
a little bit
i should probably start getting into
plague
but we're cool we're chilling we're
chilling we're chilling we're chilling
we're chilling
oh yeah i've i've been saying all kinds
of stuff you say metal the past few days
yesterday and today it's weird
[ __ ] your barrels [ __ ]
[ __ ] your barrels
guys what do i do
did i like finish the area oh i could
just go this way like a you know like a
smarty pants
let's run
hello
i'm kind of annihilating you my guy
owned
i love that for me i love that for me
there it is again
hello joseph
oh i didn't even see
so irrelevant i didn't even see you
and x skill shard excellent excellent
excellent
note on hermes life circus one in the
beginning the circuit we already read
this
my dude
hello
yeah there's a ladder right here how do
i get over her
how do i get over her
how do we get over her
oh
uh the circus seeks to
procure small-sized animals in any
condition to use in performances flyers
runners jumpers whatever if it moves
we'll take it interesting parties please
contact they are really
struggling on employees
seems like
yeah yeah yeah i'm liking it guys
i actually am
i will not cap on a stack squish willow
with you right now i'm liking this
the more i play the more i like
okay let me go this way
yeah that doesn't open up to anything
it is on pc that is what i'm playing on
right now
i'm trying to get
how do i get on this ladder
there's another ladder
in here
in here
oh
is this a ladder ah i can't [ __ ] see
that ladder bruh
i'm old and can't see
everyone spam old
old
yo what okay
okay this looks badge i can't see where
it's coming from though
hmm
i see this ladder okay
severely aged
the music's kind of like funny
lit
ah we gotta we gotta we got a weird boy
here
i wanted to heal but you didn't let me
i need to get out of wherever that is
healing
this guy's goaded
not anymore though
okay we're good we're good we're good
does he not see the other ladder oh my
god bro does he not see the other ladder
is this guy [ __ ] old and blind
play this game for two hours so i have
to try something new only be
disappointed with the gameplay music and
lack of diversity and builds
i'm not disappointed yet this is fun i'm
having fun this is fun
okay let me do this
there we go
boom boom boom
all right got a consumable we'll take it
this man had coffee this morning i did i
did i did i did i did
hello
hello
you're dead kid
bad at the game
okay
don't forget about the hammer does
really good damage how do i use it i
already forget how is it why
no
why am i forgetting what the hammer does
yeah you really gotta commit
thank
you i'm definitely gonna die here though
it's a guarantee
yeah
we're gonna have to go again there
why did i think it was why okay it's
stolen by the claw got it got it got it
is he a mini boss wow i went really far
back
oh my god
leave me alone
leave me alone
you can't do that
well i am really hyper
let's run back
yeah i feel like uh being aggressive is
just better
that is definitely the vibe i'm getting
right meow
leave me alone leave me alone leave me
alone leave me alone leave me alone
it would okay
yeah it was a little off there
it's hard to see when he's freaking
attacking
oh
now stop
bro this guy's insane
maybe
i tried
dude the the second attack there it's
it's delayed and i i already hit it and
it's over
okay i like it though we're learning
we're getting better
we're learning and getting better
oh my
that hurt my ego that's all it did was
hurt my ego
yup harder than melania
harder than melania
we've died more to this guy than the
first boss
response easy
response easy
i panicked
panicked again
okay so they can just stick right
through that
okay
they can just stick right through that
if they want to man
that was not the first boss well it's
still open
okay it felt like it
all right
he was a big boy that i've never seen
before
try and kick me fat
dude
leave me alone
yeah reading his attacks are a little
difficult i ain't gonna cap
i am not gonna cap on a stack with you
right now
bum
just want to keep trying though
okay let's run let's run let's run i got
this i promise uh oh
yeah he can just go right through some
stuff huh
you have not followed me
any other time
lady
okay
we're all here for this one now
excellent
i fell
fine with me
no
we probably have to beat him
i don't know like
you missed
i thought he'd go again
good
who the
this is bad guys
i'm not making this easy
i'm dead
oh
man
i don't know i haven't seen the first
boss i said i thought i'd face the first
boss you guys are like that wasn't the
first month
that wasn't the first month
now i don't know what the first boss is
just run past them it's an ego thing at
this point man
you know this you've had this feeling
playing these games before
i also feel like i'm getting better the
more i fight him so
okay just run
you sound like cartman that's the point
frank
okay come on baby
i pressed the deflect button sir
whoa
can you climb ladders
i am not fighting you down there
maybe it'll be easier
probably not
all right
that's good enough for my ego
okay yeah that that's just satisfying
and nice
that's just nice dude
that was pointless
starting to understand
how stuff a work a
not fun fighting them again and again
i'm having fun he just fell down so
i ignore him now
why do i do this why do i do that
funk
man's got deleted dude man's got deleted
okay
okay
i hear
oh you
hello not a good time
not a good time to read not a good time
to read
okay
oh oh
what is this
oh
you do that after you get up okay dude
so you back slap got it you back slap
no i wanted to deflect
okay
i'm so stupid
so
there's no point in doing regular
attacks when they're in the green
like there's no point right
no point this area is hard holy crap
okay let's run through
let's just run through
but kind of kind of get get my bearings
back on attacking and stuff hold on
okay feeling better about it saber does
very little against green okay
that's what i'm getting
hello shin how are you
hello
sir
okay that's fine
yeah the fist guy was kind of easy i
just kind of [ __ ] it up at the end
there to be honest with you
to be honest with you
can enemies attack each other
you're dead
you're no longer alive
excellent
seven seven and a half
what's wrong with that
that's really freaking unfortunate
i love how good i did that until i
didn't
i
wow
i fought that guy perfectly
perfectly
until i didn't and then i'm dead
that's definitely a parry check right
there that is very true that is a parry
check
i was doing so good
and then i died then i died duh
you're annoying i'm gonna kill you every
time i run back up here now
yeah that was a really good attempt i
just
the green is confusing to me maybe i i
need to upgrade my plague
i think that's our next upgrade for
suresies dude
for suresies
to get a little bit stronger
let's keep it going i want to just fight
spear guy
you
[Music]
gonna have to heal
i don't understand what [ __ ] hit me
three times there
like the claw doesn't do
it doesn't stagger them at all
it's just like taking [ __ ] from them
that's what i need to
to figure out about the claw is i'm
taking away their green health and i'm
taking away their ability
that's what it is it's not really
anything that's gonna like affect their
posture or whatever
see that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah unless i charge it
yeah yeah but that's hard that takes
more time
yeah i know they interrupt attacks do
they interrupt just green attacks or all
attacks
the throwing the thingies
jake ah this is so hard
this is extremely difficult to like
understand like when you should be doing
your claw attacks and when you should
just be regularly attacking and then
deflecting there's a lot to learn here
this is hard
we're learning though we're learning and
getting better
practice with a spear here
okay
um
yeah it seems like i don't know if it
i'd call it like super armor
i just don't think the claw
is meant to
do that besides just get rid of their
green
i'm just calling it green
okay
i love how these enemies just randomly
decide to like join in
that's annoying
why didn't that work somebody tell me
what the [ __ ]
did i do it too late
i have no idea why that didn't work
the because i threw the feather
at a green attack and i saw it hit him
and it didn't do anything
weird
bloodborne gemming
no
is neo considered as souls-like yes
yes
i don't think it's when it's just about
to make contact
i definitely haven't done that every
time
[Music]
oh i just pressed the wrong button man
that was it
ah
what is the point it doesn't do anything
to a man
finally
we're getting better
sometimes to get better guys you have to
let your ego just like get absolutely
annihilated
just like that ego annihilated that's
fine
sir
and also that animation after killing
him was really cool and i enjoyed that a
lot
i did i did enjoy that
why don't you open from the side you
[ __ ]
hmm
because i see a resting spot down there
a beacon over there
how do i get over there
yeah metal's ego is absolutely insane
i bet i have to go around
let's get it
let's hit it and quit it boys
and girls
animations can get a little laggy
but they're good
is it over here
nope
excellent excellent let's go down here
because i saw it this way
are you another one of those
thingies no you're weak
you're weak sauce
okay guys this game is cool i i'm a fan
i like it
this is nice
yeah it's not as polished but it's not a
60 game you know what i'm saying
hello ma'am
i don't think it's on the ps4 i don't
think so oh we're all the way down her
huh
i don't have any heals boys this is
gonna be badge it's gonna be real badge
let's get it
that doesn't count huh
let's use it
let's use it
okay you only get one
i forgot
i thought that killed me i really did i
really did i am almost dead however
it tried to bait right there it really
did
i i love how it just doesn't do anything
it just did nothing i i
i throw down an ultimate attack on the
ground this guy's just like what up bro
i don't care at all
the staggering
seems inconsistent but it's probably my
own freaking fault like i don't know
w's in chat keck w's in chat you're
annoying
we're going right back there hopefully
these mini bosses stay dead i would
assume they do
hmm
thanks fiction have a great day
okay when they're committed to an attack
they never stagger
that's good to know
okay this one's not here anymore
three
sir
oh this feels weird sometimes that's all
i gotta say
it feels good when it works and a lot of
time i feel like i'm getting screwed
just uh just to be honest with the
experience thus far
i need to do this come on now
your head in the game get you get you
get you get you get your head in the
game
[Music]
sir
i need this guy to not be here
guys why does the feathers just not work
sometimes dude it just didn't do
anything
i guess that was just too late i i think
that's the only thing i can think of
i'm scared
i'm simply
scared thank you
okay
it can't be a souls game because the
enemies aren't thrice as tall as you
good point good point good point
although you could argue that some of
the best bosses in the souls games are
your height or close to it
like humanoid
you know what i mean
depends on what bosses you like
this guy down fisting down fister down
boys
good stuff
does it feel
as light as sakiro
um i would argue it feels lighter not in
a way of like
not that way but like uh
it's not as polished so it feels lighter
it doesn't feel clunky i've heard people
say that it feels clunky and i don't see
that at all
i really don't
but it just like it
clunky and animations not working
sometimes that
is different to me
but maybe that's what they're referring
to as clunky
it feels okay to me really does
am i going the wrong way
what's your favorite bloodborne boss
i know he's the first one no i like lady
maria the most i think here we go this
is where we want
yay
he's not taller than you in every way
she's just taller than you it's like
melania
[Music]
okay
um let me crack these boys right her
excellent excellent excellent i have two
potions
which that'll help us out a lot
okay unlock talent follow-up claw talent
shortclaw long claw
long short
oh i thought it'd just be called that
here let me level up and then i'll have
more
uh plague
rank that up bro rank that up
there we go
uh potions those are locked
upgrade
um
yeah i would like that
and then maybe
oh i don't have enough never mind
let's do this then
okay
like weapon
what are
these hand axe knife halberd let's use
the hall bird i like that one
whip
oh wait so
i don't want to equip it
you can use your fists it's kind of cool
okay there we go
unlock talent so now we have four
first long claw talent
this one press rt again after long claw
to perform a second attack that seems
huge
uh give the enemy one stack of bleeding
debuff on the second claw landed yep
let's go
about dodging
during certain hit on animations press b
to get up quickly
it may be worth it eventually
um when successfully dodging an enemy
attack gain one stack of a defensive
buff i think that could be good
i probably should put something into
deflecting
the enemy counter-attack gauge is
reduced lb in defensive mode increases
the amount of energy restored actually
all right let's just do that let's get
those down
okay
why is this uh
er
er
er
you can upgrade these
wow
this game is so deep dude
this game go this game runs deep with uh
upgrade stuff here this is cool
interact
very cool
okay we'll figure that out as we go
along
um
where am i
oh okay
how's the gameplay so far really fun to
learn
oh this can't be a boss right no shot
this that's not a boss room can't be
can't be a boss room
was that a card
okay he looks cool
all right what up dog ultimate
when a red light appears before enemy
attack
they will perform an ultimate that
cannot be deflected dodged or
interrupted instead
corvus must avoid the ultimate's ranged
attacks
did i deflect any of that
okay you're a homie
ow
okay
yep
yep
okay
yep
all right everyone strap in this is
gonna take a while
strap in boys
my boy's back actually i just spent all
of it
i feel like my deflects aren't working
i ain't gonna cap on a stack
he laughed at me
okay i got two of them excellent let's
just learn the deflects
one
there's a delay there's a delay there's
a delay
i'm dead it's over
i like the music
but this breaks me dude
[Music]
stop doing what you're doing please
i can deflect those two
that's lit
what are you doing
stop get some help
you like that deflect right there boys
what did i just do
[Music]
okay that was better than the first one
better
improvement
yeah you can't spam you got to get the
timing
for sure for sure for sure
seems cool though
all right we just gotta learn let's go
whoa
[Music]
okay not bad
you deflected me bro
i i felt like i did that right and it
just didn't do anything
yeah when you get stuck in that you
can't do anything dude
good
better
damn perry the claw perry then claw
perry then claw perry claw perry then
claw
hey we're learning we're learning we're
learning
that was hey each time each each attempt
has been an improvement
right
i don't think the game has any online
stuff as far as i know i could be wrong
i am not sure
i left out before he just let me hit him
and now he's like yeah
all bad stuff right there guys
all of that was bad
[Music]
what does this thing do
let's find out
what is that what is that
i can't tell what it does
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that felt really good
that that right there where he does the
double swipe and you can double deflect
feels exactly like sakiro
that felt nice you can dodge
indefinitely when it's on
ooh okay thank you cool
i like this dude this feels really good
like the the gameplay feels really solid
i'm not i'm not gonna cap with y'all
that freaking delayed kick dog
bad
uh he's doing weird stuff now
delays bro delays
you can really hold that down
i think i hit him a little bit
[Music]
like that
you like that voice
[Music]
i didn't like that at all i didn't like
it i didn't like it i didn't like it i
did not like it
[Music]
nerd
okay okay i'm you know this is this is
gonna take a while
guys are there three health bars it is
that the two little dots next to his
health bar like am i struggling to get
through the one
yeah i do have a second claw attack
you're right
son of a [ __ ]
all right let's go
[Music]
oh i really gotta heal here
so is this the circus leader by the way
oh this is the guy who put up all the
signs
odor
lore video
[Music]
that was just stupid of me huh that was
just bad
okay
[Music]
dude his health bar went so down once i
started using the double claw
like i was i was annihilating him there
ringleader odor
pulled the door but he's the guy who was
putting up all the wanted signs
like help wanted
he asked how many phases oh god stop it
stop it boys
i wanted to do that a lot earlier
and it didn't do it
freaking delay
three
[Music]
i couldn't even see and i deflected bro
i'm so good
dang that's cool
uh oh i was wondering why they were
telling me about an ultimate bro what's
going on
stop
stop
stop
okay
three there's three there now there's
three there now boys there's three
[Music]
i will never understand the delay i
guess
[Music]
i don't know how much health i have but
it's not a lot
there it is
okay okay at least we got the stage two
esther thanks for the three months yay
it's three months and i'm drunk as [ __ ]
what up dude thank you so much thanks
for becoming a member
all his moves are now extended and his
ultimate now usable
okay we just gotta we do phase one a
little bit better
we're pogging out pogging out pogging
out
that was a bad start
okay i went in a little hard there no
cap
awaken thank you for becoming a
tarnished appreciate the memberships
guys thank you so much welcome
thank you thank you thank you
really focus on deflections yeah i just
didn't know
if the attacks changed at all
but thank you again awakened and esther
you guys are great
yeah this guy's really hard dude i'm
enjoying the fight though i'm enjoying
learning it
it it's fun
okay
okay
okay
hey guys if you miss if you miss your
deflects you're dead
okay
you missed the deflex you die
what's the tree
is it a tree
sticks let's go
uh
[Music]
that feels so good
you like that
way better that time
let's go let's go let's go
put me in coach
heal immediate
man dude phase two is quite different
different
my activity feed has just
interrupted itself everybody hold
everybody hold okay we're good we're
back
seven yeah i've died a lot thanks guys
okay when you get the deflex down though
feels good dude
feels good
okay
we got this
[Music]
so hard to tell
sometimes he just stays there and
sometimes he just backs out like wow
this is the first boss
is this boss number one
[Music]
there's a steep learning curve here my
man
hit lower vid
you guys want lore on thinesia
i'm i'm pressing the dodge button
absolutely nothing happening okay
uh
[Music]
there it is
heal
double
okay
excellent
we're getting there better
no point really going adam there
[Music]
wow
batterish
gotta back out and heal
[Music]
i tried
i i just i hit the button way too late
i saw the green it's it's really hard to
distinguish the green
between the like throw the feathers to
counter it
and the um he's healing green animation
because i thought he was just kind of
healing there for a second i'm like wait
a minute it made the noise
where it
goes which means that he's about to hit
an undeflectible attack
which
yeah that's hard this is hard bro that's
all i can say
i'm trash
aren't i boys
i'm hitting the deflect button and
nothing is happening sometimes
i'm never gonna get that bro
kill me restart let's go again
my
god
i mean if this is if this is the first
boss then nobody's used to the mechanics
so i don't think you can compare it to
like the elden beast you know i'm saying
because that's at the end of the game
that was a bad time to use that guys
really bad time
[ __ ] hell
what's breaking there is he just hitting
me harder that time like
what's the difference
it's weird
because sometimes you'll do that attack
and like nothing will happen
stop running away
[ __ ]
dude
this game is all about flow
it's all in the flow boys
sometimes i flow with the fight and
sometimes i get annihilated
so
[Music]
we are getting
we are getting better i have to keep
saying that you need more potions
yeah that's what people always say they
everyone said that in my playthrough of
elden ring like dude you need more
you need more flash need more tears i'm
like eh
we can do it
okay
why does that hit me
like did i miss the deflect i can't tell
because i feel like i'm hitting it
i guess i wouldn't get knocked back if i
hit it right
[Music]
that delay i'm never gonna get i promise
yeah kill me let me restart
it's hard to tell i just don't know the
ins and outs of the game yet to where i
i know those differences you know
this is just the first [ __ ] boss it's
a real wake-up call in this game
and that delayed kick is getting me
pretty much 99 of the time
okay come on
i like i'm hitting the deflect button
and i swear to god it just doesn't work
i swear
that could just be being a [ __ ] though
oh my god dude
like i'm pressing the button and just
like
it just doesn't happen
i think it's
i think the timing windows are just way
smaller than sakiro
like if if you're really missing it
because i would say that sakiro's
deflections
are actually really lenient on when you
time it
but this is like if you don't get the
timing right guys
you're just gonna get [ __ ] hit
it's like a harder securo
i i'm never gonna get that
come on
[Music]
i don't understand how i miss that i
don't uh
oh that's my least favorite attack
clearly
what did i do wrong
i don't know
[Music]
all right come on
we're not probably not going to beat him
here so we just learned deflections
[Music]
he kind of phases behind you
there which is kind of tricky
yeah sakira really does let you spam you
you can't spam in this game
you can't
this is very hard
it's a cool boss though i'm having fun
learning it
don't ever ask me why i did that there
[Music]
i don't know either
i'm just being stupid
uh
did you did anybody see me throw my
feather and it did nothing
i don't understand the feather
the feather
sometimes just doesn't work
i saw me throw the feather at him and he
just goes i don't care
frigg
what's the verdict i don't have one yet
this is the first boss
with backing up yoho
bloodhound step
[ __ ] you
oh
i'm so focused right now dude
i'm beyond focused
beyond
haha
huh
[Music]
foreign
no there's a third swipe on the second
one
now there's a third swipe
a third swipe
maybe we should try leveling up i
i don't think there's any point in that
i think
it's just hard
that was way better though we're
learning stage two
we need to do better on stage one
but that was a great run have you tried
winning thank you metal for your help i
appreciate it
damn it come on
uh if i knew
when this guy would [ __ ] stagger
consistently
that would help
that could that almost couldn't have
been better if i didn't have to heal
twice
okay come on
come on i i can do stage two without
getting hurt at this point i feel it
i really do go behind me fly behind me
what are you doing stop it
it looks so bad
but i'm hitting the [ __ ] deflect
button and it doesn't do anything
heal tell me when to do that joseph
tell me when to heal man again please
it's really helpful when he's just
slapping me around
and you can't heal you forehead
well
ah
dang it
i can hurt him pretty good but
i mess up too much
he didn't even do this first phase
almost
come on
come on
go behind me
this is not a time to do it
i don't i don't get it
you know when i said it's not a time to
do it and then i just did it again there
you go
hi ludwig have you tried leveling
vigor to 60 and summoning your mimic
tier no i have not i have not
thank you for the three months i
appreciate you it's very helpful thank
you very much
let's go you died
i'm having fun learning the boss though
it's fun
hard
but fun
it is frustrating though
when you feel like you're hitting the
the deflect button
and it just doesn't do anything
like that right there i was i swear
it's hard to tell though
i'm
you saw the first deflect and then i'm
pressing deflect again and it just runs
right through me
i don't get it
i don't get it sometimes
he gave me a tip for memory shards like
dude i have zero
i can beat him though it's very clear
that i can beat him
double tap that's what i'm [ __ ] doing
i'm saying it doesn't it doesn't work
it feels like it doesn't work i bet the
timing's just bad
okay he just did he stagger once there
a single time
hold on
i i feel like this is all about deflects
someone said
counter gauge is reduced slightly
increases deflect time but decreases
fleck damage are we even doing deflect
damage
[ __ ] it it's cool that you can move
these around depending on the situation
that's cool
i can't go all the way down i don't have
enough
we'll just do that
okay
i feel like it's [ __ ] worse
it's literally worse
[Music]
[Music]
uh
it's a whole different
animation now
like the deflection animation like the
the particles aren't as big when i
change
that that's what i noticed
dude
[ __ ] hell
ps3 graphics where the [ __ ] are you
getting that from the game looks pretty
good to me
he has three graphics you'll play on a
ps3 i promise you it's it's [ __ ] not
stepping dodge
yeah i haven't used that once
further increases the black time but
decreases the fleck damage fine
i like the game so far i'm having a lot
of fun it's this first boss is just
really hard
i wish i could see except there's a
[ __ ] tree there
hey back up boy back up
[Music]
so i couldn't tell if that was
undeflectable or he is healing i'm
pretty sure he's healing
it does feel better
harder than gundyr
uh yeah gundyr's a joke compared to this
guy
rp walk
stop doing that jake
[Music]
guys does the feathers just not work
[Music]
no i pressed them
yeah comparing this guy to gundyr this
is like lady maria versus
a bird
like an in real life bird
the feather will not interrupt a red
attack it wasn't a red attack it was a
green attack
[Music]
that it's just not [ __ ] working
i swear
[Music]
oh my god i deflected that one attack
i'm so proud of myself
guys i found out what they did to
bloodhound step
they put it in the mesia
yeah i don't think that's his ultimate
the one i'm talking about
i might be wrong though
if i could get to the stage with more
than two health that would be so great
[Music]
the timing here the timing on those five
combos right there is so [ __ ]
difficult i i can't be i can't even
explain it
it's so hard
i
the just the the timing is weird
that was good though
what do you see says yeah phase four
absolutely absolutely
all right come on come on come on we're
getting better
use the thing
i wouldn't have gotten hit so many times
there if it worked when i press the
button
[Music]
that was my fault just terrible timing
to use that it is so weird to have these
like insane animations like that where
i'm pulling a green spear out and
stabbing him multiple times in a row and
you can't stagger enemies with that not
even normal enemies it's so [ __ ]
weird to like get that in my brain that
it doesn't do anything
[Music]
break
come
on heal me with that
uh
okay
[Music]
break
what is jedi scum saying i didn't even
see what they said
so
[Music]
[ __ ] attack
that attack seems really rare
it's odd
okay
he's saying this game copies the death
screen
there are death screens in like every
game what the [ __ ] that's such a weird
point
come on
[Music]
yes
let's go
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
tell me what i'm doing wrong there man
that's so dumb
the [ __ ]
it hasn't worked once
[Music]
i'm so
i'm so mad at myself
yes
don't tell me there's another one
oh that's weird
oh that felt so satisfying
just once i finally got those five
deflections down dude and i think i did
it two or three times there
oh that felt good
give me give me
hello child
that's not what the kid's saying is this
all that happened
oh
no
okay so i can keep moving around okay
cool
hold on let me take let me take a peek
why can't i go over here oh wait that's
where i came in
hey guys every every game ever is a copy
of something else and that goes for
everything
that you can think of
okay this game is is not a copy of any
like a direct copy of anything it's its
own thing with
similar attributes to other things just
like everything else
so calm down
thank you
thank you
okay do we go back here now oh
oh this is cute
[Music]
oh i love metal so much have you
acquired long lasting potion oh you have
acquired a long-lasting poaching be
equipped in the motion okay that's good
good to know
i want to talk to her
up voice acting corvus are you ready to
recall
rest
go item
odor's vile core
this was taken from odor
this is much too strange as the ring
master of the circus odor has received
large amounts of pure blood
yet why is there vile blood on his body
hmm is this this does not look right i
think you head back to the sea of fools
and gather more information
okay
okay
can i level up mommy
was this open before
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
the odor has been has dissipated
you just lost all progress on that level
i told you many times not to cancel
i don't care that's fine
i feel like we went through a lot of
that area
and that was the final boss
that's fine
most of the area like the area wasn't
very big to begin with uh okay
long lasting potion
should i equip this
yes
also just because you got you guys tell
me to do things uh does not mean that i
will
just so you know
i might read it but i might not do it so
calm down it's my playthrough not yours
thanks
thanks
can i get a thanks
ooh royal garden that's next
bark for me right now
meow
[Music]
how do i level up i need a thingy
here
do i level
[Music]
i don't know if i like the hall bird
what's this one
uh
oh the miasma buff
hmm
i think this is cool to have just
because like we can steal other things
from other players
or from other uh people we fight against
use yes
use forgotten feather
oh okay
um i guess i'll
oh rest beacon menu got it
of weird okay
oh i can upgrade this
[ __ ] it let's do it
uh level up
let's just get ever like these to five
unlock a talent
we gonna maybe we just unlock everything
in one thing at like one thing at a time
uh when successfully deflecting or
blocking attacks some energy will be
restored sure let's just focus on
deflects until we get it done and then
we'll go on to another attribute
okay
continue to recall royal garden
wait one of three
oh see i don't know why you were mad
that i like didn't
i still have those places that i can go
to that's totally fine to leave that
area
oops my bad
okay royal garden
metal and jake are totally a thing
where do you guys get that from just
because she's a mod
huh
huh
you can go back any time you want that's
totally fine
royal garden
royal garden
okay
hmm
hello young one
i like the music
hello
sir
lore
oh
you stop attacking me sir
damn
give me that head
ikey boy give good head oh
this reminds me of dark souls oh never
mind it's just a regular
okay
are you guys talking about hentai
hmm
you guys sure act like it do we
i don't know what you guys are talking
about
neat
hold on step
you need to go away
excellent excellent
i like this game man this game is fun
big
fan big fan stay over there sir
i see the ladder right next to me
hmm
i see what this does i see what this
does
oh this looks like a bad boy here guys
did i just get hit by a [ __ ] arrow
bro
what
i don't get hit by the arrow
you won't calm down
this guy's like what
oh
um that okay
i'm sorry daddy
wow okay that guy has so many moves
i could yoink his weapon that's a good
idea i should have done a charged attack
at some point
because i can join this right here
and then use it
and then they drop stuff when i do that
okay arrow boy over there not cool
sick
[Music]
yeah i feel like i should put on the
general potion again this one doesn't
seem very good
let's put that one back on
but
yeah getting immediate health seems
better than progressive health
let's go
let's go
go
what the [ __ ] just hit me
okay
you are stupid what
okay shield bash
bad
[Music]
it's bad
but i learned the skill i'm not ever
gonna use it but i learned the skill
it's so hard to tell when these guys are
attacking
especially especially when you just like
took an hour to learn one dude's move
sets
and then you have no idea what these
guys do
makes them hard
[Music]
for
real
i'm dying to just basic voice now
yep it's so hard to tell
man
okay let's go back
this is run through let's go to the big
boy
[Music]
i don't think i went this way
let's try it
yes
uh oh
whoa
i'm gonna try to steal this guy's stuff
of took a hit there
kind of sucks
[Music]
come on do the thing that i'm holding
the button down for all right
this plague weapon seems really good
no i wanted to trade him
damn these animations are so sick dude
okay good kill good kill
not bad
oh we're in trouble
ah
stop it
get some help let's go down here
hello
hmm
this is weird i like this
damn shields down
bruh
you have to
okay
you have to learn the moveset of
every enemy in this game or you're just
gonna get hit by everything dude it's
really hard
what's this
okay we got some more memories huge
scythe is amazing
yeah can i change my like base weapon
or is that just um
flag weapons
this guy seems sad
sag for that guy
okay can we get a checkpoint here soon
dude
let me try the scythe
let's use it on somebody else i really
like that you can do that it's cool
okay
that seems cool let's try again
wait
yeah
neato burrito dude need no burrito
the [ __ ] is this
enemy or cool
i'm just not gonna attack you never mind
now i will
ow
no backstabbing not to my awareness now
oh
i tried to get his plague but then i
died
let's just run
bombard
running running running
running running running
i mean yeah the
honestly the learning curve here is kind
of insane
why is my camera being pulled to the
right
is this a mini boss looks like it
got a bunch of flighty boys
oh come on
nice
okay i definitely over thought this guy
like by a lot
you can sprint on ladders just hold down
the sprint before getting on the ladder
and it's fine okay that's cool
okay this is on that it's very specific
the game would be very short if you
didn't spend all the time learning
deflect patterns i mean i think that's
the entire game though don't you think
it's like the whole thing
i would say
wrestling deflect what the [ __ ]
i think i was already staggered
i'm really struggling with these guys
they're really hard to fight
um
excellent
hardest game you played yet this one i
don't think so
i would say sekiro might be the hardest
game i've ever played
cool that was cool
is there a mini boss
i didn't see it
hey checkpoint
check
light the beacon [ __ ]
okay we got 2 000 boys
i think we can level up
let's get our plague up a bit
this plague seems just as important
uh like i said we're gonna focus on
deflect
and i think we're done with deflect now
we can't even do anything else unless we
want to change it up
now we'll focus on something else
uh i am never going to use the shield so
like unlock it sure but i don't care
i think i'm going to equip the great
sword
uh and then wait to upgrade it
oh i think i had a potion thing too
potion
upgrade
oh it's just one of two
oh i don't care about that that's fine
long lasting is poop
hello what are you doing in here
oh we got a witch [ __ ]
let's go this way actually
that way it looks important
oh oh god here we go
hey i fought you
and i always struggle with you
stay
[Music]
i tried i i dismissed
okay
i don't just i just don't get it
sometimes
get the health down a bit
okay
nice
we are clearly getting better at the
game
clearly getting better at the game
the illegible handwriting is difficult
to decipher injecting a tiny amount of
the blood bile into an organism will not
have any effect on its vital functions
but if a certain amount is exceeded the
effects will be nearly impossible to
control
yeah makiri counter please and thank you
please and thank you
excuse me oh [ __ ]
yeah was that a potion upgrade
i hate these guys man
i'm pressing deflect
this game is cool
i like this game
how long is this game does anybody know
welcome massive good to have you
okay
greenhouse order
what year
10 hours all right we're not beating it
today then
i can't stream for 10 hours
i got to make a video
or i have to make an ad for the video
15 hours wow okay that's pretty long
how many zones are there
this looks spooky scary there's a lot of
blood in here bro
[Music]
a lot of blood in here
hey 15 hours for a uh
less than 30 game i bought this game for
like 20 bucks
i'm dead
the [ __ ]
okay
what's the next video you'll find out
when it comes out
okay now you're saying four hours
it's a big difference from
uh 15.
big bloodborne oh you're friendly hi
sorry i didn't mean to attack you
obvious
corvus do you remember me
probably not i'm emerald
i
also have a little credit
for your presence in this world you have
unlimited potential
maybe we should
see this conversation as an opportunity
corvus do you have something you want to
ask
odors vile court i can't believe odor's
research has made such progress he
should not have been wasting his time on
the sideshow act
if he came to study under me he probably
he could probably become a greater
researcher than eismi
this is the lore girl okay
transformation experiment report number
one
the transformed are so interesting
and are such challenging research
material using the infected as carriers
we use alchemy to grant them new life a
very interesting concept though
interspecies fusion was required and
that was no easy task
the successful cases were few and far
between corvus you were one of the lucky
few so i was infected
oh
i was infected
and
i'm like one of the people that actually
like the cure worked on
or at least the experimentation worked
on
okay that's all i can do with her that's
cool
you can find her in zone one
well that's okay
let's drop down here
i'm dead
yeah it shows it undead
a lot of con a lot of similarities
okay
let us continue onward
into the void
oh an elevator
it don't move
oh my god
geez that man jumped my ass
i went this way
okay they literally like don't want you
to run away
what are these burning [ __ ]
that guy was swinging before i even came
around the corner
what a legend
guys i found out where they uh put all
the rivers of blood it's
here pressing the deflect
that man dead as hell
oh i was right here
that smells
let's see if i have any poppy boys
[Music]
items
i have lots of poppy boys
okay
potion upgrade upgrade potion
health recovery
uh level up let's do plague let's just
get everything to five that sounds
pretty pogerwager's smile
and let's continue
okay
big boy
ew
it's a bat
whoa maddie it's
you whoa this looks cool
hey man
okay remember i can deflect just because
he's big don't mean i can't deflect
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
cool sound design
[Music]
[Applause]
oh he's healing
whoa
okay what's going on with that
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
why does it keep healing
[Music]
so
i have to like stop him
[Music]
how the [ __ ] do you avoid that
can you join her healing power
that's a good question we should try
okay so this thing just heals a lot
that's pretty much what i got out of
that
now
so
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you can totally stop them
i want to heal too though
[Music]
bad timing
[Music]
use the thing oh
[Music]
do i just have to run away from that
it kind of sucks
[Music]
okay that's a bite animation got it
it still heals anyway
i stopped him and he still heals
[Music]
all right
let me move please thank you
no the backslash okay i'm learning i'm
learning i'm learning i'm learning
that's a red attack can't be deflected
or interrupted so i just have to run
away
it's hard to tell when he's doing the
like
a different attack
compared to the big one but i guess i
gotta look out for the the animation
this attacking way too many times way
too many times
[Music]
[Music]
oh i tried
one little healy boy
oh [ __ ]
okay i i got it now he goes way up in
the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you
okay
[Music]
holy [ __ ] dude
the animations in this game are really
cool that boss was easy once you figured
it out
but that was cool i like that
that was sick
can i get these back did i even have
anything
oh yeah it's 1700 huge
so the timing on it's generous i think
because of the
deflect i have all my deflects
uh why am i burping so much all my
deflects are fully upgraded
does this all that happen
probably not but let's just move on
yeah that was like two tries right that
was way easier than the other boss but i
think this is just an easier area
hello rick hi lizard how are you
how how the hell are you pairing that
wing slap i'm literally a god okay
i actually don't know that i have no
idea
fast acting potion
shorter potion using time and more
number of potions recover instantly
50 healing effectiveness
is that good does anybody know
are you ready to recall
uh help me out here gurley
let me see if i have any poppy boys
uh i don't excellent good
rest
level up uh
let's go vitality let's increase that a
bit
yeah why is she moaning interesting
uh let let's focus on
reform fast
press rb right after dodge perform a
stab attack yes
and then saber attacks and stab attacks
fill the counter what are these over
here actually
so this is increased saber inger okay
in air attack i'm not huge on the in air
after forming execution some health and
energy will be restored on the level of
the enemy give me that right now
uh increases saber attack damage
yeah okay let's focus on the saber now
leg weapon don't care
don't care can we upgrade this nope
uh
the timing on it
mission structure inside missions
reminds me of neo
how's everything so far worth a try i
think it's definitely worth a try
i think definitely so
i'm enjoying the game a lot actually
more more so than i thought i would
anything change in here as i progress
this is cool
yeah health back on executions i think
that's an easy choice
continue to recall burmese fortress
let's go
but both main boss fights that we've had
so far have been really really cool
actually really sick
the first one i think was my favorite
just because it was the biggest learning
curve but even that one it was easy but
it it was fun and it looked cool
you know what i'm saying
i never played mortal shell
so i'm not sure how it compares to that
okay that guy we've fought before whoa
whoa
relax
this reminds me of
like the deep root depths
in elden ring
like where you find godwin
do it on stream i reckon you like it
yeah i think it's pretty far out of
relevancy though don't you think
that came out a while ago
this game just came out and people have
been talking about it so
seem like it'd be fun
all right grassy boy just got ruined
slower and heavier combat i'm not even
sure i'd like that but it's okay
a good souls like is always relevant
well
relevant in
the youtube algorithm how about that
is that okay to say
but i don't know if i'll make a true
i don't know if i'll make a true video
on this
like for the channel but i might
okay i'm definitely learning the
controls
top of key fortress wall key okay got it
yo
yo yo
yo
yo
i had to do you like that buddy sorry
can you fall fall please
okay i could fall but you can't
excellent excellent excellent good
the movement looks weird
it was hard to get used to
but i i definitely like it a lot now
i think i can upgrade
no i cannot
it would tell me
i thought the same thing at first but
it's grown on me a lot
okay
i've seen action but never played it
oh
oh god
what just happened
are we still live right now what what
the [ __ ] just happened
did you guys hear that
my obs was just like nah
are we live right now
hello
yeah y'all heard that
okay let's see how many times that can
happen before i actually like figure out
i'm gonna get shot in the back and like
have it not happen
nah obs does that sometimes like it'll
just be like
i don't wanna do it
i don't wanna
uh okay
having these archers here are weird
you're annoying
i don't like it i'm
out whoa
like gravity's been reduced uh it
doesn't feel like that at all
like while playing it doesn't feel like
that in the slightest
okay ladder
i mean i can't right now joseph
that was my next thing on my list
however
yeah it doesn't seem like there's fall
damage although i haven't really been in
an area where i can fall that far
you know
annihilated
yo what up bro
god damn dude
i'm a big fan of the sound effects like
the sound is nice while i'm while i'm
fighting
um
the animations are really clean
once i started to understand the
mechanics of how health works in this
game
it's like a cool flow
i think i might make a video on this
game
here tell tell me if you guys uh would
like this or not because um a long time
ago i used to do
so a long time ago i had a second
channel that had like 20 000 subs from
valorent
and i
like i made valerant tutorial videos or
whatever
and i did that for a while until i kind
of burn out of the game didn't want to
do it anymore so i started doing
something called jake's takes
which is just like me reviewing new
games that came out it'd be like less
than 10 minutes
you know like a review of a game like i
think i did one on go satushima
um so like
i could start doing those again where we
play games like this and call it jake's
take
because i was gonna do one for stray but
then i was like eh i don't feel like
it's you know it's a cat game it's cute
i didn't really have that much to say
but this game could be a good start to
jake's takes
because i love reviewing games i love
playing different games as well
so let me know if you think that'd be a
cool idea
nobody else has ever tried to
rip on
riff on zakiro it's definitely not
worthy for sure
this definitely feels like sakira like
big time no i will not make valerian
content ever that's not what i'm saying
i don't have that second channel anymore
i actually deleted that channel uh like
years ago like two years ago
um and just wanted to start over with
this one
and it's going really well again
so i felt confident enough in like my
ability to make a new channel that i
didn't really mind the
20 000 sub loss
so it's all good
yeah we would only do it on this channel
this is the only channel i have right
now
okay
uh
health
for sure
we have a potion upgrade maybe we're
gonna focus on saber
let's just increase saber attack like
why not
yeah maddie was there or metal babe was
there for those
i mean they were okay right
yes unlock that
does that actually cost me [ __ ]
oh it does
i thought it was just a free unlock i
wish i didn't do that
dang
that's pain oh well we're good
we're good
those chairs do not look comfy what are
you talking about man
they look okay
yeah definitely not definitely
definitely not
okay let's go this way i think this is
where i need to go
hi grassy boy
oh no here we go
here we go
i definitely want to steal his [ __ ]
definitely want to steal his [ __ ]
that's cool
no you're kidding me that's a green
what a beast
yeah i've played hollow knight i really
like hollow knight
did you guys see that though
on the nuts
wow
i'd rather not die here
okay dude
damn
okay i got the key to the cathedral
or something
this is a cool area so far
group selection ceremony event will take
place in the fortress square only
uninfected okay
yeah what's silk song i've heard of silk
song but
i i would obviously like to expand out
to other games like that's uh like
that's obvious by the way like every
here i got it maddie every creator out
there wants to play more than one game
and if they're telling you different
they're lying i promise
as much as i love elden ring it would be
really fun to like move on to different
stuff just to keep like a breath of
fresh air in the channel you know what
i'm saying
oh yeah we got rid of the bots the bots
are no issue boys
the upcoming hollow knight sequel
oh cool
well you deleted it not hid them you
gotta hide them maddie
thank you for your help i appreciate you
very much
blood
you know what i'm noticing a trend here
like just just thinking
of something there's blood trails
all over this game like in every area
there's just like a
blood trail
to something in each area i don't know
if that signifies anything yet but
maybe
though
i feel like i've been here
definitely have okay
i'm sub for hot variety streamer
i would love to be your hot variety
streamer
do you play any multiplayer games uh i
still play rocket league a little bit
like just um
very casually
like i play ranked in it because there's
not much else to do but uh
is there another ladder over here
um
that's the only like real multiplayer
game i play right now
i mean i have like 7 600 hours in rocket
league or something but i'm not ever
gonna make content for that game again
no shot
no shot bucko
i'm gonna ban for that god forsaken game
from all your consoles i swear to god
maddie i have a healthy relationship
with that game now i swear
i promise
will you stream god of war ragnarok in
november one thousand percent
would you guys like that
yeah i'm loving the flow of combat in
this game i have a i have mostly
good things to say about this game
i think there's some things that are
like
a little janky about it but it's not a
sixty seventy dollar game
the game is o jacob i know i know it is
i i am fully aware
that that game is full of hoes
but i just don't care anymore i'm not
i'm not even a part of the community i
just play the game and when i started
focusing on rocket league for just the
game i've actually had a lot better time
like way better
now that i don't have to make content
for it anymore
okay i probably have the key for this
now i do i do how about you
do
i'm so cool
[Music]
okay that came in a lot faster than i
thought
sir
i'm calling about your car's extended
warranty
car's extended warranty sir
that's not good
i am going to go kill this guy
bow boys r-o-p in this game
i don't even know if we tell chad about
my rocket league experience dude
does anybody in chat play rocky league
here i hope all of you say no
i really do
this guy's hard
this guy must give you something good if
he's like hard to kill
i'm pressing the thingy and it don't do
nothing
you don't do nothing
obscure indie game
let's talk about overwatch it's a bit on
polish for a two dev team
wait did you just say this game was made
by two people
is that true
wait is that [ __ ] true this game is
made by two people
no
i did but the community sucks ass that
is the
absolutely perfect way to describe
rocket league the game's fun the
community is awful
and young
apparently
wow this is extremely impressive for two
people extremely
i thought this would be made by like a
30 person team
maybe like 50.
that that is incredible to me
all right this game just got way more
points in my book
way more points
um but i'll work on a jake's take for
this game
i will i think that i think that'd be
cool
do you guys like the name for that
like for reviews for the channel jake's
take
speed jake's take thimesia
what's over here i wanted to go on that
door but yep i knew it
jake's takes or jake's take
i think it'd just be jake's take
because we're talking about one game
okay i really do like this one
oceans upgrade
why are you telling me we can do [ __ ]
when i can't do [ __ ]
[Music]
isn't the game made by seven people i
don't know i'm just going off of what
chat's telling me
it makes me want to look up doug's and
digging their dev process
jake's takes fem boy made costume
excellent just just great
yeah even if it's seven people that's
still extremely impressive to me
whoa
cool
you know this game kind of reminds me of
just the vibe a bit
that's the guy who killed me at the
beginning
[ __ ] you man
what's that game that came out in
february that was like uh the kung fu
game
[Music]
okay
yes sifu
kinda
kinda reminds me of it
the music here is awesome
you must perish
why is the screen tearing on the left
side there we go
okay stage one was so easy bro
that was easy as balls
[Music]
i shouldn't have talked shouldn't have
talked
yeah he just hits like a truck
[Music]
what do i do
owie
that's what he did at the beginning
lol can't reach no reach
oh
did i just pop off bro
get get absolutely annihilated
holy
i just popped off first try
i'm learning and we're getting good at
the game
damn
that was so clean and also that fight
was really fun i think it was supposed i
don't know if it was supposed to be
really easy but it was really easy
i don't know if that was easy for
everybody but like god damn that was
easy
i just like i liked the uh
i like the flow of combat there that was
really fun
now the hard bars to start okay bro okay
i did
how do you feel about the combat josh
who's josh
is that all this happened i mean
probably not
well let's just go
yeah i don't know if it was supposed to
be easy i just like flowed really well
with that fight
his moves are really easy to
to read for sure
oh we're not sitting down this time
corvus you have worked so hard
these memories should be sufficient
we have enough information to figure out
which formula you used in hermes answer
would you like to delve into your final
memory are we already beating the game
because there's definitely has to be
like some hidden areas
not yet
not yet
hold
hold
[Music]
can i do my thing
where i upgrade and stuff
okay are subquests
has to be
extra boss
okay where do i go for the extra bosses
i might just try and finish this game
out today like maybe
[Music]
maybe it might take too long
[Music]
so i can always leave the final area
right i think i have to let's do it
i can always just like travel somewhere
else from a
from a thingy
let's go
the shaking camera
i haven't noticed any shaking of cameras
ocean of memories
thank you thank you maddie i appreciate
that
joy would love to take a take a walk
with you
okay let's get this to seven
and get you to six
talent
restore energy when hitting enemies with
saber attacks that sounds lit
uh increase the amount of energy
restored when hitting yep let's do that
uh then we can do these later
let's just keep focusing on that
ocean
no those are just the other ones i just
like the general ones
i think they're fine
try and look out for those
okay
hi spleen jelly how are you
um let's leave
where do i find the uh other bosses guys
it's these recall
wait what does this do
defeat corvus i have to defeat myself
ooh
how do i um how do i get out of here do
i do i leave like this are you sure you
want the c3 call you will lose until and
return to the philosophy
yes
i'm pretty sure i've saved up to this
point
i would think
okay
there's no new game plus feature
okay that's fine
okay lady
this is what i wanted before
[Music]
here we go
so oh it just says it on there
oh
that's easy okay subquest one subquest
two
destroy all sis
fine orders construction notebook
sure
i have to defeat my true self we'll see
am i a [ __ ] monster am i the person
that started all of this
i bet i am
okay now what do i do where do i go
you
you're trash to me now
crash
well who are you
you look like a boss
this chick looks hot
am i weird for thinking that
yeah this chick's hot
sorry
okay gotcha kinda
[Music]
easy
oh my god
destroyed
was that a boss
easy
does this game have a story yeah
it's kind of told like uh all the souls
games
it doesn't really tell you
not top g enough i bet
she's a succubus
interesting
so do i just explore
[Music]
[ __ ] indeed
oh
i'm whoops not to die here okay there we
go
this is bad
[Music]
yo you can link from like one downed
enemy to the next that's sick
did you kill any bosses after hanging
queen was gone i don't well oh yeah
i think we're at the end like we could
go to the end of the game right now if
we wanted to but i'm exploring all of
the other areas
that are clearly like optional it seems
like
what did i run out of them
i guess so
i am still not locked on to the person i
want
excellent excellent there we go
hello are you in need of help
please
i just freed you why would you try to
kill me
you silly forehead
okay what's down here
[Music]
i wish i could see but i have a giant
ball sack in my face
excellent
oh i haven't even found this beacon
before cool
get everything to seven
seven uh increases
increase the amount of energy restored
when sexually performing execution
excellent
excellent
i got so relatable come here
right
i ran out of feathers bro
come come come
all right
that works too
you just stab a wall yeah do you ever
accidentally stab walls
because i do
god those animations are so clean
when they work
oh
whoa what the [ __ ] was that
okay this is getting bad
good
hello
this guy's just full health again sick
this is the main game
from the hopeless we've kind of stopped
reading stuff
i got a little tired of reading
everything not gonna catch
that'll be one of my uh
that is gonna be one of my gripes but
with people like with a game made by two
people i don't really expect there to be
voice acting
so that's okay
okay
just kick me sir
can you stop
i don't think we'll do any lore hunting
in this game
probably not
not uh oh hello not enough hype with
this one
with this game
okay i need to kill that
or you can come over here
uh
um
[Music]
this guy's helpful is insane
wait what the [ __ ]
oh he's backing up
i think he's healing because he's not
even meant to be here
there we go
yeah look at him he's like he's
definitely glitching out see that
maybe that thing was healing them too
i'm not sure
yeah look at his whole health bar just
came back randomly
what's going on get over here come on
let's see it has to do with the area
yeah now he's losing health
that's kind of weird
there it is
uh
well i wish we could have seen that
animation because i bet it was cool
yeah that had to do with him being not
like he's not supposed to be over there
so we just kept healing
kind of weird
what a small gripe
a small one
it's fine
hmm okay is that all that there is over
here
looks like it unless i'm missing a
ladder like i usually do and i'm blind
i'm blind
looking
nothing okay
we'll go this way now
whoa
you sound cool
man that guy likes to kick oh god i
can't move
here we go
we're getting a little glitchy in these
areas getting a little glitchy
it's okay
ma'am you are
i thought i was stuck in the tree
getting a little glitchy with the
animations in some certain areas
those that's kind of one of my main
gripes is like you get stuck in walls a
lot
um and then
the no voice acting is a bit of a turn
off but it's like oh it's okay you know
whistleblower huh
i don't really have a lot of negatives
so far that can change like really quick
yeah obviously yeah they're definitely
gonna be more focused on uh the main
quest lines
which turned out to just be pretty short
in comparison to the rest
uh i don't think i went down here so
let's go down here
because like is that is that where i
fight against myself is that literally
the last
boss
like main boss
did what is this
this all that happened wait how are you
here for this
yeah
so where that was that all the cis
okay
[Music]
continue to recall
so we're two out of three here now we
gotta find our doors construction
notebook got it
yeah i don't think this game's ten plus
hours like i feel like i'm getting
through it pretty quick and we're almost
at four hours
i could be wrong
i'm here for it
okay
so are these sub areas like locked off
areas from the other part of it
whoa whoa i don't even see it
we're looking for a notebook
is it this
nope
hmm
what is making the thingies
up
now it's okay it's over there got it got
it got it got it gotta get it
give me give me give me
timmy timmy timmy can't you see
so can we just not go over there
ugh
nice
i ca i can't see
where it's emitting the thingy
maybe i'm not meant to yet
over here
cool cool
yeah i have a lot of positives with this
game that i was that i wasn't expecting
i wasn't expecting the really large like
uh skill tree
oh i just missed everything there
shoot
haha mine's faster than yours
ah
nice
remember when we struggled on that guy
like way earlier for like 30 minutes
look at us now guys look at us now
just being
total
beasts
i think the learning curve on this game
has been really fun
i've had a good time with it
okay blood going down there
which is the dusty busties we gotta go
over there okay
okay
hi
go around town
which you tried
a [ __ ] a you tried
and you failed
where did you come from
excellent
okay
let's get it
this is the drop down there we go
ow
i will say the the side stuff at least
so far in this area is kinda
kinda boring in comparison to
the main stuff
the main stuff that we've gotten so far
has been really cool
like really really cool
where do i go though i'm looking for a
notebook
hmm
oh maybe it's over here now
i don't think it's that
excellent
beacon
i mean yeah i saw the beacon but i'm
looking for a notebook
was that a newbie no that wasn't a new
beacon that's where i started from
for sure for sure
for shizzle my nizzle
can i go up here now
no
all right okay okay
did we
jump down don't want to do that let's go
around again
in order to go this way
that's where we drop down and now let's
not drop down
all the blood
it's collectible memory
more enemies
absolutely annihilated kid get [ __ ] up
okay this can be bad this can be bad
okay let's get these little boys down
one at a time
yeah a lot of comparisons to dark souls
for sure
a lot of differences though ton of them
now we're doing all the side stuff
before the final boss
nice
i've definitely seen like a lot of
variations on animations with the mini
bosses it's cool
well let's circus poster we don't need
that
[Music]
excellent
we are looking for
i think it was my notebook right
corvus's notebook corvus every say his
name
just making sure hold up
i'm starting to form an eldering theory
in which old
got in combat with a formless mother but
only proof as of now it's is a shitty
blurry image
because this is a from software game
which image
this is new
um see if we got any poppy boys which i
think we do
we got a lot of them
15
rests
the game is on console and pc
let's do
strength
unlock a talent
okay
just focused on that for now upgrade the
potion let's do amount of potions
increase
bada bing bada boom
now we got five look at us go look at us
go look at me go look at us go
okay
by me
oh
she's scary
whoa that sound
is cool
nice
you would dodge your perry main i'd say
i do both
trying to
i think both is required more likely
than not
oh there
notes of hermes okay
the grave mogan palace smog area where
two animals maybe just two dogs and two
lions
are holding a weird trident that looks
similar to moak i don't remember if this
grave is in any other areas
um
i'm not sure
absolutely
destroyed
why can't i turn i can't turn my camera
there we go
oh i got stuck on a stair
pull me up
ah i got hit
hello
yeah attacking seems to work
it seems like everything is needed to be
used interchangeably you know what i'm
saying
you gotta get good at everything
where the frick is my notebook bruh
rip that guy holy rip that guy
let's go back this way
because i don't know
seems like we can go up somewhere over
here
i keep getting stuck on [ __ ] i don't
think i should get stuck on
this is clearly how you're supposed to
get through here
we kill the cysts
excellent
unexpected
unexpected to say the least
there's another gripe i have
oh there we go
oh we were looking for odors notebook
not mine okay cool
ghosty boy get me out of here
what was i saying
oh one of my other gripes is that the
camera gets stuck on walls like all the
time
like literally all the time
yeah i don't know why we're talking
about eldon ring right now either but
you know that's what he wants to talk
about that's what he wants to talk about
can i go this way
yeah
no
okay
i can't level up
i can upgrade this again
oh [ __ ] yeah dad
i feel like i need that very much let's
just keep these up
you know we're at six we're looking good
we're looking spice
we're looking hello fresh
[Music]
oh now there's more
god of fools defeat the god of fools
let's go
the god of fools
that seems scary
i've learned that if i have thought of a
theory
in like a minute
i you know i should probably keep it i'm
talking about me here i think you're
totally fine lorenzo
but like
every time i've brought up a uh theory
that i kind of thought of in like the
moment
people are like well no
you know what i'm saying
people get really mad
about elden ring lore
and it's really weird
oh my god
this is sick
whoa
[Music]
cool
ah
yo what up huh
ow
you come
whoa
whoa
it doesn't look like he can reach back
here
relax my guy relax
we are gonna go go go go go go go gadget
go
do these people just not care that he's
here man
i mean wow
what is he spraying
seems kind of pointless for him to be
there like that
like spraying it nothing
what is he doing
kind of weird kind of weird kind of
weird
uh
body will steal it
okay
okay
got a feeling this is like a gimmick
boss
i'm gonna wait one more time i don't
know what's over here
looks like a whole lot of nothing oh god
sir i'm gonna need you to stop
that didn't work
man
literally can't see that sucks
we're gonna deal with it though
and all these people really don't care
everybody's sleeping man
run
a
boys
no i'm sure they helped raise this guy
to like you know wherever he's at now
but
uh just the fact that he's like
destroying everything
should be like maybe we shouldn't be
here type of deal you know
oh
did not need anyone else entering this
area
this is so awkward with this [ __ ] guy
here man
no don't tell me i'm dead [ __ ] you i ran
through so much man
there's so much going on there
yeah i guess they're fools right right
oh we ran so [ __ ] far
if you share theories reddit will steal
it dude like i don't
i don't think you can steal theories i
just don't like
it it's not a weird conclusion to say
like people came up with like
had a similar theory to yours
it's really not considering we're all
working with like the same thing
but
i see what you're saying
okay i'm just gonna [ __ ] run i have
to do all this again
i'm not fighting anybody though
bar body
the heck just hit me
there's a checkpoint over there
how do i get over there
where do you get that
ma'am i'm gonna need you to leave me
alone glitched stay glitched
that is so
[ __ ] annoying
that's the beacon at the entrance okay
you're right
you're right
dang
it okay this this is annoying not my
favorite boss
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
let me
you serious
the [ __ ]
no clue what they expect me to do with
that bro that's that was just weird
bro
climb
climb
can they climb
nope
how's joy she is amazing and super cute
as per usual
go go go go go
you still focus down below
i'm gonna go ahead at this real quick
go go go go go
oh come on
okay
you
uh
that's really bad
genius
[ __ ] christ
this is annoying this section is bad
i'll just say it it looks amazing
i i don't like it this this gimmick is
trash
[Music]
this gimmick is uh not fun
reminds me of uh
what's that dragon's name in dark souls
3
in the secret area
i forget the name of it
we just have to run through everybody
looks really cool though
not my deer
the one not in dlc
like the ancient wyvern or something i
think is what it was called
game's good this is my least favorite
area by far though
by far
it's really annoying
this crazy chick dude
i i can't lock onto the other guy i just
can't there we go
for the love of god
no idea why i'm doing that
hopefully this is good
nope
i don't i don't know how to use my
ability
and it's really [ __ ] annoying
cool
i'm straight up hitting every button and
it's not doing anything with her
like i took her ability and it's just
not doing anything
god that's pain why did they [ __ ] put
her up there
yeah the game's really cool this this
area is [ __ ]
not fun
cool
i love how i get through that just fine
sometimes and then other times like i
can't [ __ ] move at all
putting a hard enemy in the game it's
not like it's the process of getting
there that is stupid
this is stupid
i'm not a fan of it
it's cool though
cool
doesn't matter if you're dodging she
will hit you there
this is so [ __ ] annoying
dude
this this chick
up here with the [ __ ] entire arena
shaking everywhere because of the giant
dude
is so [ __ ] annoying dude oh my god
yeah the enemy's hot she's [ __ ]
annoying
[Music]
wake up you clearly placed annoying
enemy
let's put a sleeping chick on the
ladder
i don't know man it seems like if you
get hit by anything on the ladder
you get knocked off of it and she has
like kunai and [ __ ]
i almost thought there might be a
shortcut there
i wish i could sneak right now
let me go
[ __ ]
dude
[ __ ] off
i swear to god
so
thank you
i almost threw
my god
may i never return here ever again
now i don't know what to do
i swear i'm dead
i should have killed the pus thing i
should have i should have calmed down
and killed the pus thing i swear if that
lady is up there again
i'm getting off for the day
this level is awful
awful
okay she doesn't respond thank
the lord
get up
you're on the ladder you dumb [ __ ]
yeah i was literally gonna rage quit if
she's still there
very cool looking boss though very cool
however the gimmick can
suck my buddy
yeah no [ __ ] madness thanks for the help
man
i'm just running through it
all right at least she didn't respond
okay
why did i do that
on down
i can't tell what i'm aimed at is there
a person in there
yep there we go
the game has been awesome up to this
point
game has been very cool up to this point
you gotta be kidding
where did i just fall
okay
okay
now
get me out of there
yes this boss gonna be like one hit or
something
uh
okay none of this is a checkpoint
just want to point that out
uh what's up i'm reading
why give me something to read if i can't
read it man
i can't even tell where i'm going
anymore
why am i back here
oh does that slinger bro
do i have to kill these things
nah he's making that happen
i'm confused
is that a walkway over there
do i hit that thing
i mean i'm literally past the area with
the cis so it doesn't even make a
difference if i killed assist
i've already been there
i don't know why i'm going back
you know
all right hold on i guess i have to go
down that way
wait no i don't
this seems really weird i ain't gonna
cap
this this boss is absolute [ __ ] dog
[ __ ]
what am i supposed to [ __ ] do there i
ran out of places to go
what
god this sucks
i'm killing every puss sack now
even though nothing is indicated that i
have to
let me move [ __ ] you
i'm getting very frustrated with this
one
yeah every game does have one or two bad
bosses this is just like really really
annoying
am i supposed to jump out down on its
head right here or something
oh i can't move
i literally can't [ __ ] move
i
got wedged between whatever the [ __ ] is
on the bridge in that enemy
holy [ __ ]
this is trash
[Music]
i hate this more than the bed of chaos
i never thought i could say that i never
thought i could hate a boss more than
the bed of chaos and this is just taking
it
plus does not matter that's what i
thought
nah it's in the game that means it's not
optional
so
what was i missing before
i'm confused on that
turn me around
i just want to be done with this so bad
i don't know where to go
we'll go this way i guess
dude all the shaking and random gas
everywhere is really getting to me
where do i go from here
where the [ __ ] is a ladder
[Music]
are we just saying there's a ladder when
there's not
oh
i fell through the floor over there
didn't i
that's weird
i didn't think i went up here before so
i didn't think i had to go back
strange
where did we fall through the floor
whatever
this
this might be worse than the bed of
chaos and that's really hard to do dude
all right here
makes sense
don't tell me we kill it in one hit my
guy
what is my guy doing
oh
i love gimmick fights
gimmick fights are so fun
wow
oh wow
[Music]
we did all that just to [ __ ] press
one button to kill the giant boss that's
great
bruh
[ __ ] christ
all right well that was the first
optional area
are the rest of the areas better than
this one
i hope
because i'm about to bust a
bus to something somewhere you know what
i'm saying
yes that's all i have to say thank god
that's over
that's it
[Applause]
that's all i can think of
that was by far the worst one okay
excellent
that was like three hits
there's more
defeat mutated odor
oh bro
yeah this game's way longer than i
thought even though you can go directly
to the end of the game
kinda cool kinda cool
this is gonna suck balls isn't it
yep mutated boy
uh oh here we go
[Laughter]
so anime whoa
oh come on man
son of a [ __ ]
okay
oh okay
all right guys let's learn a new move
set
an entirely new move set
to learn right there guys
excellent
excellent
i can stop that it's not red
can i here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god this is just
[Music]
so hard
it's i can't
i can't tell what he's hitting me with
bang bang bang bang
nice dodge
there we go
yeah that's that's tough we we got a
little better there but
how do you block an aoe like that i'm
not sure it's really hard to tell like
what he's attacking me with
because there's like his arms and then
the weird tentacles coming out of his
back
it's tough
but once we started learning the
movements it got a lot better there
really i don't think i'm gonna get my
things back
well i had to use a health potion just
to get my [ __ ] back
that kind of sucks
yep i got a little
i got out of the flow after just getting
hit a bunch of [ __ ] times there dude
i might just let these uh these ones go
i really might because i don't have
enough that level but
just enough to not want to lose them
i just don't want to do it every time
i gotta remember to parry that
it's really hard
not that one that's for sure
um
this this is really tough
and
i guess i'm looking too much at the
where i'm getting hit from instead of
like
the
what is it
the rhythm of which they're hitting me
that's what i have to focus on is the
rhythm
there we go
but then like i knock him so far back i
can't hit him again
that sucks
oh i'm dead
[Music]
yep sometimes he does his like green
attack there and sometimes he just does
an overhead smash and you're [ __ ]
dead
[ __ ]
well this is more enjoyable to learn
than that [ __ ] last boss i mean [ __ ]
dick dude
[ __ ] dick on a stick real quick
yep the overhead smash i it's the same
rhythm as the other one where he does
the green attack
but it's a totally different sequence
[ __ ] how
[Music]
uh
he i'm trying to
i'm literally trying to get back and
heal
and there's no time to do so like almost
no time to heal in this fight so far
[ __ ] christ
yeah we used it against him
the earlier version
gotta back up really far
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
i can't tell if that's an attacker he's
just backing up bro
damn i'm getting really frustrated
i'm being a [ __ ]
[Music]
uh
holy [ __ ] he has like 10 billion moves
to remember
okay
you can literally see me dodging to the
side but i guess that this still hits me
cool
dude we're like five hours into the game
i know the red [ __ ] is undodgeable
but i'm using dodge to run out of the
way
the animation looked like it missed me
but still hit me
yep
that's the overhead
[Music]
yes
come on get me out of there thank you
[Music]
thank you god
that animation's so [ __ ] clean
cool
oh i actually just randomly popped off
there that's all the difference was
the curtain will soon fall for humanity
and a new show will begin
shut up odor
you're a stupid idiot that's all i have
to say
i hope this is all that happened in this
area like god damn
well
that one's way more fun to learn it's
still frustrating i think i'm still
frustrated from the gimmick boss
but man
that that one was way better
obviously
you got any poppy boys
nah
are you ready to recall okay so we're
done with the sea of trees we did
everything there
find a key to the underground laboratory
defeat bird okay
i've beaten this game but can't stand
sakiro to me the game is easier but does
not mean it's not good i'm replaying it
trying new builds i'm having a fun a ton
of fun actually
in this game like new builds
i don't know how you do that but
how do you do new builds in this game i
think it's all just kind of like
whatever you level i guess
and there's the talents
that's true
yeah never mind you can totally
all right i think we're done no we could
have done this
whatever i'm still working on sabres
what is this one actually can i upgrade
you now no
we're chilling
all right let's go fight her boy
we gotta kill erd
hello
you just learned how to parry an elden
ring
good for you esther good for you
this is just another entrance to the
place we fought that one guy yep
oh now we can actually go up here
hello
anything up here nope just you
i don't believe there's any multiplayer
to this game
well that guy just wrote my butt
that guy wrote my butt cheeks and split
them open
and it hurt
let's go this way instead
never mind there's absolutely nothing
over here why is this area here why do
we have a walkway over here my friend
going down not in
i think pvp would be really cool in this
game
potentially
i think it would all it would all be
skill
of like uh parry times and deflects and
stuff like that that actually could be
really cool
excellent you're stuck
uh
cool cool cool cool
cool the sub area here said defeat erd i
don't know who that is
now i think we do we have the long claw
i think
i think i'm all done with my sword
upgrades so i can start working on
the claw stuff
excellent
reeve
uh
it's a checkpoint okay
cool i'll take it let's rest
yeah i got this game for like 22 dollars
so i think so far i've definitely gotten
my money's worth like a thousand percent
in my opinion
now
oh i know you
you're where i got this from
lol nerd
uh
hi morris how are you
this guy is so beefy
[Music]
i'm on steam
mistimed
this guy's tough
got a lot of help
not sure how that didn't work
um a little
dumbfounded that it didn't
cool
that was a
big boy
a very large boy
it's up here
i'm still at the end of elden ring and
giving myself some rest before facing
the last boss
in elden ring
how many of you guys in chat have like
taken uh a break from eldon ring
because the game's been out like what
five months now
it's kind of a long time
[Music]
his announcement
is the latter
yeah
you know sure whether it's short or long
you know just like any type of break
oh this is a wheel
interesting
i guess i'll spawn right back up there
i want to fight at all
there we go couldn't have said anything
okay
bum
i see dead people
this area is pretty cool
it's giving me some souls vibes
can you rest without getting hit
go away yep sure can
there we go
excellent
where the frick is erd
i still get the itch a lot to go back
yeah so do i every now and then for sure
oh man
kind of popping off right now
get
absolutely
blocked on
you are stupid
bye bye
i've been having a lot of fun with this
game like i wouldn't still be playing it
if i wasn't
it's got some problems but again a game
made by two people uh
it's gonna have that
it's extremely satisfying to play it it
really at least in the terms of combat
it holds up to sakiro in my opinion it
does
which is hard to say
because akira might have the best combat
of any game
i ever know why i did that
um difficulty is definitely there i
think it's pretty balanced
um every boss that i'm like wow this is
a big struggle you can learn pretty
quickly depending on your skill level
obviously
um
i think it's fair i think it's good
i got jumped in an alleyway i got jumped
in an alleyway i got jumped in an
alleyway
i'm about to jump you back oh wait
nevermind
yes the 20 something dollars that you
pay for this game is definitely worth
worth it if this game were 60 dollars
i'd say probably don't get it but it's
not so
you know what i'm saying
it's england
i got some rosemary bullies i got some
rosemary
the flip is herb
i don't know how to fight this thing
don't know the moves
okay
one two one two
never mind it has more than that
obviously
really struggling to deflect this
chick i
cannot figure out the timing to save my
life
no i wanted to heal bro but it just
keeps going
i do want to get this game but god of
war ragnarok coming out soon kind of
want to save up for that yeah if you
don't you know if you're going to be
like oh i really want 70 or 60 whatever
it is for uh gotta wear ragnarok
you should absolutely save your money as
much as you can
that's just smart financial stuff man
but if you see a game that you really
really want to play
[ __ ] play it man
i probably need to kill her
to get this gate key never [ __ ] mind
goodbye chick
i don't want to fight her i don't like
fighting her
where is old
another checkpoint
or you can always watch me play it
you can live vicariously through me
oh here we go this [ __ ]
oh this is somebody else
badass she's wearing jeans
huh
[Music]
he's got multiple phases
bart nugget
[Music]
[Music]
you are fast as [ __ ] boy
[Music]
ow
my soul
what
was that
this is a cool fight
i like this
it's kind of like someone like us
don't hit me okay i'm dead
i'm dead
i like this fight though i i'm i can
tell i'm already already gonna enjoy
learning it for real for real for real
let's
go throw me in again baby
[Music]
[Music]
owie
[Music]
sick
uh that's pretty fast [ __ ]
dude can you go back to what you're
doing before please
thank you
i'm throwing i'm just playing bad now
what is that what it's a trap
oh god
she's a she's a thirst trap she's a
thirst trap
do you plan to make lore videos for this
no
definitely not
probably not
i don't know
it's not in the books right now
is the stream lagging for anybody else i
don't think so
okay
girl
heel right in your face
[Music]
[Music]
uh uh
[Music]
okay i'm pressing
like i have to hold down never mind i
didn't ever have it i'm an idiot
[Music]
i can't even [ __ ] hit her
[Music]
huh
no i thought she might
might maybe stagger
uh
no i pressed it
there's not much lore to be honest
we don't even know why we're fighting
this chick i mean we probably do we
would just have to look
into it it doesn't tell us why but like
what other games don't tell us anything
you know what i'm saying it doesn't mean
there isn't lore you know
hmm
yes [ __ ] i hate that attack it's so fast
i press deflect and it's like well too
late i can't dodge
[Music]
i'm not pressing the [ __ ] there i don't
know why it's deflecting
[Music]
huh
[Music]
that attack is my biggest struggle right
now
excellent
you are so fast it's kind of nuts
[ __ ] i can't tell when she's gonna do
that
okay that attack's pretty much pointless
[Music]
oh yep my bad
oh we're talking about elden ring now
huh
to me it seems like this chick wants to
fight us
kind of true
what
what
ah
no i
hate that attack
[Music]
[Music]
this is the best fight in the game so
far this is so cool
yeah what would you guys rather be more
excited for bloodborne 2 or like elden
ring dlc
ah
literally just trying to heal there we
go
huh
uh
this chick is so [ __ ] cool
huh
[Music]
[Music]
that seems a bit unfair
let's throw that out there
okay couldn't even tell
let me heal one time one time
finally we got this
the second stage man
if there is one okay
what is this checkup god
okay more of those
[Music]
no i don't know why i held that down
dude
this is really cool
this is my favorite fight for sure
what'd you guys all say elden ring dlc
elden ring 2 that elden ring 2 won't
ever i don't think eldering two will
ever be a thing
ever
i really don't
[Music]
i really gotta figure this [ __ ] out that
attack is
annihilating me enough
uh
[Music]
uh sometimes she gets staggered by those
and sometimes she just doesn't man
i'm waiting for the waterfall
yeah what's her build no kidding
i think eldon rings sequel
i think an elderly single where we have
to face the other gods after becoming
elden lord be the most badass from soft
thing ever
i mean don't you guys think that would
just be dlc why would they make elden
ring 2
you know
miyazaki never even wanted to make dark
souls 2 or 3. by the way miyazaki had
nothing to do with dark souls 2 like he
wasn't involved in the making of it at
all i don't think
um and then because there was a dark
souls 2 he didn't like the way that they
ended it so he made dark souls 3. i
don't think if dark souls 2 ever existed
that dark souls 1 would probably be the
only game in that franchise i really do
he said that in like uh interviews
things like that
um
i think he's gonna do more things like
making sakiro making elden ring you know
demon souls dark souls like he's gonna
make
new stuff all the time which i think is
great than just making elden ring two
obviously they were gonna make dlcs for
all of this stuff there's no doubt about
it there's just so much money to be made
in that but
he's not big on sequels
[Music]
[ __ ] christ
[Music]
no i got her man
it's the first time i've even done that
whoops i [ __ ] oh god that's an insta
i was doing really good for a second
there and then i just completely
folded my butthole
backwards
is there any relative
relevant great tree like the earth tree
before the earth tree itself
that's what i thought that there was
this tree
and then the
golden order or the greater will took
over the tree
we're talking about that
as much as dlcs would be cool a sequel
of a whole trilogy might be cooler i
don't know why though like like why not
just instead of making people buy
a new 60 game which they would but it
would take them so much longer to
develop elden ring 2 than it would be to
just make like
five dlc packs for
for eldon ring you know for eldon ring
one
i think making a sequel would be
kind of dumb
but
they probably will
eventually like
a very long time from now
[Music]
leave me alone
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's bad that's not what we want
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know where the other one is okay
a little unlucky
cool we'll take it
[Music]
oh you see that slide out of that dude
that was awesome holy [ __ ]
i have to stop her from doing that
not sure what i did wrong there but okay
i guess the timing was bad
[Music]
[ __ ] i didn't think she'd do that
man dude
she is hard as hell man
how does dlc work on new game plus can
you only access the dlc after beating
the game to begin with
um in past games you just need to do a
certain section of the game
uh
and then where like you have to do
something first and then it can be
unlocked you don't have to go through
the entire game
usually
yeah if you [ __ ] that up you are done
dang bro just that combo
she's sister frida hart or millennial
heart i don't think you can compare
she kind of reminds me of lady butterfly
from sakiro
yeah you know like i hey let me
let me preface that i would love elden
ring too
that would be sick of course
but are they going to do that probably
not
oh man comes out of nowhere for my brain
plus almost got it
[Music]
oh doubling it up huh okay that's a
first
i'm really only struggling
with that attack
literally just that one
hearts i have my deflect
upgraded fully
all the way so
it has no it's a skill issue
not uh you know sometimes it's not about
upgrades it's about getting good at the
game ugh
[Music]
wrong button
my fault
completely
uh
[ __ ] man it comes out of nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
i can't figure out when she does it
my brain no compute
there we go
uh
[Music]
oh
yep we got different moves now we got
different moves
i don't know what these do in stage two
ah
heal man
i press the button twice
that's a long [ __ ] combo man
it's a [ __ ] sweep
wow
[Music]
hey that was our best run
but holy [ __ ] she is hard
that is very cool shin
yeah i didn't do a cool slide this time
you can literally check how long i've
been live for by just like hovering your
mouse over the screen
i think
but uh
almost six hours
okay come on
getting better
hard to tell what she was doing there
thing
that's really unfortunate
that sucks
ugh
come here girl
[Music]
really none of those worked
i threw a feather i could not
begin to understand why that didn't work
[ __ ] you
that's not good
okay
i'll do the cool slide if i can
that does look really cool
[Music]
are you stuck
never seen that
why didn't the feather work
why didn't the feather work
i i don't know how else to dodge that
besides the feather and maybe a
perfectly timed dodge that i don't even
know i have iframes for
but
i threw that feather as she was loading
up and it just didn't [ __ ] do
anything
i don't get it i don't get it you're
hungry i can feel it
i could eat
i could eat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh [ __ ] i thought she'd do the three
man
[Music]
[Music]
clean
very clean
how do you dodge that without using the
feather
really pissing me off that the feather
doesn't work dude
[Music]
no way
so many moves she can do there and it's
that one is so fast
[Music]
it has to be right at the end
the timing has to be perfect or it
doesn't work
foreign
oh
my god
right in the middle
it's fine
look
no bro this was so good
damn it
so close
it's it's literally just those green
attacks that are like
giving me
any trouble to be honest
now i'm struggling with everything
cool good
huh
[Music]
[Music]
that attack's pretty tough too
[Music]
we'll take it
they're all right next to each other
you're a horror for doing that you are
you just are
yeah i deserve to die there i got way
too freaking greedy bro
this game out of photo mode like ghost
to shima i haven't been like
super uh
the game looks good it doesn't look like
amazing to me like not like anything i
would do photo mode for but some areas
look really cool for sure
you have to use the ford's opponent
dodge skill
uh i mean i've dodged it to the side
before so
that's not true
this is really hard to do but i bet that
makes it a lot easier for sure
i don't want to [ __ ] with any of my
skills right now
or talents
[Music]
no
man
known
that was close
[Music]
what
okay we're getting to stage two pretty
consistently now
still very difficult
that's like a nuke dude sick
nice
ugh
huh
[Music]
okay i almost had it
leave me alone for half a second chick
i didn't do anything
that's so unfortunate man
yep
damn it
oh
i think my headset's all [ __ ] up
does dodge even work
yeah
of course it does
but it's definitely more parry base like
deflect base
i get so locked into her second phase
that i forget her first face
[Music]
yeah
going nuts
[Music]
[Music]
i
really am struggling on that man
it's way harder than it looks to know
when that's coming
[Music]
uh
you not please
yeah let's just spam the one thing i
can't dodge man
[Music]
hmm
uh
i love when i press the heal button and
nothing [ __ ] happens
uh
just too fast
okay i got it the next one we're gonna
we're gonna get it on the next one
we're gonna get in on the next one
i know exactly what to do here
100 guarantee we get it right here
what's up
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[ __ ] you
okay maybe not this one but but soon
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
this boss is cool as [ __ ] it's freaking
awesome dude
[Music]
it's really [ __ ] unfortunate the
feather didn't work man
i i think the feather
the timing on that is kind of [ __ ]
insane but i guess get good right
he's literally an optional boss yeah
it's really good though
wrong button
and get comboed
get wow bro
i got knocked in the air on the ground
the aoe goes up and then she just hits
me with her combo as well and i'm dead
in a second awesome
that's awesome
[ __ ] christ
ugh
huh
[Music]
just pulls it out of nowhere usually she
does like a move or something
[Music]
[Music]
okay that could have been that's as good
as we've done round one i think
that's that's really good
ah
that's so [ __ ]
what
dude the double
[ __ ] you
holy fart
she can just keep going with those
all the wrong buttons chad
all the wrong buttons there
i was pressing l2 to deflect
that's how that's how much i just threw
because i was doing so good until she's
like i'm gonna use that [ __ ] dumbass
attack three times in a row
me and me
i'm i'm close though you can really tell
i'm close dude holy fart
[Music]
not the time bots not the time
not the time
okay
really not the time
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know if i've dodged that attack
a single time
it's really hard
[Music]
that [ __ ]
all right wow okay
[ __ ] you
just kill me i want to go again
i crossed the room and ran because i'm
so
fast metal i'm just fast as [ __ ] boy
i'm not really proven that right here
but
please confirm
hold on
old
nope that's a scam
report spam
scam
it's probably good that i'm taking a
small
stoppage here
okay
back into the flow this is the one
do you believe cause i believe
stop telling me to change the [ __ ] i
have on my character i'm using the one i
have
[Music]
it's not about the items it's about
getting good
it's just such an odd place for you to
use that
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
dude i'm
[ __ ] the feathers man [ __ ] the feathers
the feathers are trash
they're so hard to use
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
the feathers are trash
[Music]
[Music]
no i thought that would get me out of it
it's so dumb that she can still hit me
while i'm flying in the air
[Music]
[Music]
weird place to use that
it's an indie game made by apparently
two people which is
nuts
someone in chat said that though i don't
know if i believe it
but maybe
then someone else in chat said seven
people
yes
[Music]
hey
nice
oh you can suck my
everything suck it all suck it all up
and dry
[Music]
[Music]
kill me yep dude i had such good [ __ ]
rhythm there and it was all ruined by
her just like
throwing
three two or three of those [ __ ]
daggers that light up the floor and then
i back up into one
uh kinda arc caves
hmm although she's wearing jeans
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[ __ ] you
okay
get me away from this wall
pretty good
yes
cool i literally got it off and it just
didn't work
i love that
whatever that's fine
huh
[Music]
it kills me it kills me bro it just i
have all the heels in the [ __ ] world
and there's just like never any time to
heal in stage two you just [ __ ] can't
it's so
hard [ __ ]
huh
weird timing there
i hate you
bro
huh
[Music]
[ __ ] you
come on
thank you i have to focus though
thank you
i didn't know what to do
holy [ __ ] we got a heel window
[Music]
you're such a [ __ ]
huh
get out from the wall
rookies
yes
[Music]
get out of here
oh
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
some guy with cancer thank you for the
five dollars i appreciate you very much
that boss
was [ __ ] awesome
yes i struggled through it i did
but it was still freaking sick
that boss was so cool so well designed
so pretty with beautiful animations with
beautiful soundtrack in the back
that's a s tier boss
so cool so much fun to learn
great payoff after doing it
freaking sick
i can't imagine playing this one-handed
it gives you 10
000 little little dudes too
my
low
milo
wait how much more is there there's a
lot more to do so we've got
we still have to find evidence of the
coup
we have to find a key to the laboratory
we gotta we got a lot more to do we got
a lot more to do
yeah this game can get pretty long i
mean we could go and finish the game
right now if we really wanted to
i think i need more health but uh
you know i want to do all the stuff
because i think this game's worth it for
sure this game is really really fun
like really fun
to learn the mechanics and stuff
[Applause]
more so than than i thought it would be
what did i just do
okay there we go
[Music]
and i wish i had that
well i should probably have had that for
that entire fight that would have made
it easier
oh
but a six and a half hour stream is
pretty long there guys
i think i'm gonna be done
i think i'm gonna be done
i would like to play this tomorrow
on stream um we're actually i'm gonna
have to wait until i have time i'm not
gonna lie
uh
because i need to make this next lore
video by
tuesday so that means i have pretty much
tonight and tomorrow
uh to get it done so i'm gonna try and
get a video up by tuesday if i do have
time
uh then i will hop on stream and play
this again because this is sick
um but other than that
that's going to do it for today
thank you all for being here you guys
are great thanks for counting down
how many times i died and
talking to me through it so appreciate
you guys very much
um but yeah i'll be back on stream soon
to play this i definitely finished this
out this game's really good i'll
probably makes it make a jake's take on
it which we talked about earlier where
um
it's like a review jake's take so that
you know i used to do those years ago
but
you know
i'd maybe i can bring it back who knows
but
we'll see
look out for a lore video on tuesday for
sure with another sponsor like i'm
really happy we're getting all these
sponsors lately it's really cool
um
not gonna tell you what it is obviously
but you will see on tuesday
morning probably morning we'll see
uh other than that guys
you all have a great rest of your day
great rest of your night get some food
i'm gonna go eat because i'm [ __ ]
starving
and uh
see you soon
peace out guys have a good one